Onion!
That's me!
That's you!
Onion.
Josh, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Onion!
You mean Gothminto?
I can't just... I can't just...
I can't just every time!
Wait, hold on.
I forgot to do something, actually.
One second!
One second, one second, one second.
One second.
I forgot to do something.
Hold.
OK.
I fixed it.
OK, good.
Hi boss, you're cute.
OK, bye.
Bye.
Don't leave!
Hey Minto, you want any waffles?
I'm making waffles.
You like waffles, right?
Anyone else want waffles?
I'm making waffles!
Oh my gosh.
Good thing you're making waffles, because I hate pancakes.
Well, I don't hate pancakes.
I just don't like them, you know.
Minto is cute forever.
We just started!
Let's not get too into lying right at the beginning of the stream.
You don't want to form bad habits.
It takes one Minto stream to form a bad habit, I'm telling you.
Waffles are better.
I just don't like how doughy pancakes are, you know.
And then they like... I don't know.
Is there something about pancakes where they absorb the flavor, but they sometimes don't taste like the flavor, you know?
I was about to head to sleep.
Go to bed!
I'll try and be quiet.
I can't guarantee that.
Cutie.
Crawfles.
Is that a croissant waffle?
But pancakes drenched in syrup is so good.
But they're like too doughy, right?
Minto hates my favorite breakfast food.
It's so over.
Happy Thanksgiving, Canada!
This year I'm thankful that Minto is Minto.
Thank you, dog strings!
Happy Thanksgiving!
Crepes?
Oh, crepe waffle.
That sounds good.
I like crepes.
I like crepes a lot, actually.
She's making the case for Krispies and dunking on sauce.
No, no, no.
It's different.
Put some chocolate chips in those pancakes?
I'm just... I'm just not a fan.
I like waffles.
I'm making waffles.
Today we're gonna be playing Shrek.
Not a game.
But, well, yes, it is a game.
But I...
I...
Happy Thanksgiving to my fellow Canadians.
I'm very grateful to have met you at Otakutan.
I'm grateful for my job, good health, best Oshi, etc.
Gustav Mint, thank you!
It is a game.
But it's not like Shrek the game.
It's Power Wash Simulator.
DLC of Shrek time.
Duloc.
Let's go in.
Ah, there you are.
What took... I can't speak.
What took you so long?
What even is a touche?
Encounter a curious and stubborn stain on the way?
As you are no doubt aware, I am soon to be made king.
Is this Lord Farquaad talking to us?
By marrying the most beautiful damsel in all the world.
Snow White.
No wait, I rejected her.
It was the one after.
Mint Phantom.
Minto Swample.
When are you playing Shrek Super Slam?
What's that?
It literally says on the bottom.
I wasn't there yet.
No matter, the point is that the privilege of rescuing said maiden from her dragonly abode was won by a flatulent ogre.
Which left the vanquished knights here in Duloc somewhat...
Aggrieved?
What does that mean?
It's like aggravated?
That's what I thought it said at first.
Consequently, they let vent their frustrations rampaging through the town on their way out.
And I'm not having my bride to be's imminent procession soured by unruly actions of ennobling greats.
I found out recently that Lord Farquaad is supposed to sound like Lord Fuckquad.
And it blew my mind.
Farquaad.
Fuckquad.
So is the R silent?
So feeling a little melancholy after seeing the end of MGS3 again, let's wash away the feels with some Shrek silliness.
Yeah!
I guess I can kind of hear it.
It's like a...
Oh gosh, there's...
Cartoons do this all the time, but Dreamworks?
Oh, is that a toilet?
Oh wait, I think that's Lord Farquaad.
lol lol I think it's meant to look like a toilet, right?
Rest assured, knight, those responsible for this outrage have been incarcerated.
How do I...
There's a way to like...
No, hold on.
I forgot to look at the controls.
One moment, everybody.
Controls.
There's one where it's like, you know...
Aim mode?
I think so.
It's a trash can.
Oh!
No...
Are you sure?
It's the public toilet.
Like, very public, you know?
It's the very public toilet...
Of...
This city.
The most public.
Yeah, we gotta clean it.
Oh boy.
It's gonna take a while, isn't it?
This place is humongous!
Oh, it's a mascot mask!
Oh, I see it now!
I see it now, I see it now.
Oh my gosh.
I still rest my case.
Remember when Markiplier Farquad said...
Simpler internet times.
Where did that come from?
Why is that a thing anyway?
I do not know the lore.
Deep fried meme.
I know some people hate the subtle...
Whatever, the subtle...
Foreshadowing trend recently, but I kind of love it.
It really feels like we're so close to YouTube poops coming back.
Which could be a good thing.
Or a bad thing.
I don't know.
I don't know how the internet is nowadays, but...
I'm kind of here for it.
It just reminds me of a simpler time, right?
Let the memes flow.
I kind of went on like a...
I went on a nostalgia trip the other day...
And I watched a bunch of the We Are Number One...
Like mashups and things like that.
Just for funsies, I was like...
This is like one of those rare times when it feels like...
The internet has banded together...
For a common goal, you know?
Robbie Rotten, my beloved.
I know!
I loved...
Loved those videos.
So good.
I did that too a few weeks ago.
Did you also see that it was like the anniversary recently?
And that's why you also binge watched it?
I often caught myself watching old Vines compilations.
Oh yeah!
Those ones are really easy to get into.
And yes, the title is not clickbait.
I will be doing some Shrek karaoke...
Later on.
Maybe like once I clean this one, you know?
We'll do karaoke and we'll clean...
Just kind of like how I did...
If you watch the Spongebob DLC one that I did...
I did some Spongebob songs while I...
After I cleaned.
So it'll be the same.
Break stuff.
My throat is recovering.
There's plans of collabing with Leah again.
Yeah, I mean, not that I have plans...
But I would love to collab with her again.
She's actually in a thing that I'm working on right now.
Thank you for gracing the VMute stage with KLP48.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh, KLP was so cute!
They were so...
Oh my gosh, I was like...
I knew their setlist beforehand, obviously...
Because I was told when I will be coming on and everything like that.
So when I saw that they were going to do Shonichi...
Which is one of my favorite AKB songs ever...
I was like...
So excited.
Favorite ice cream?
Cookies and cream.
You thought I was going to say mint chocolate, huh?
Will you sing songs from the Shrek musical or will I be Smash Mouth?
There's not just Smash Mouth songs.
But I've never seen the Shrek musical.
Is it any good?
Oh my gosh, I'm kind of excited for the Wicked movie though.
People are really ranting and raving about it.
I don't really know anything about it except Ariana Grande is in it.
But everybody...
All the posts that I've seen about it...
They make it sound so good, I'm like...
Is this actually going to be good?
Is it going to be good?
Shrek musical was pretty mid.
Actually, there's like one...
Song that I've seen...
Ye olde trash.
There's like one thing I've seen about Shrek musical.
And it was like one of Fiona's songs and it has like...
I don't remember exactly how it went so I don't think I'd be able to sing it but...
It had like her younger version singing and then...
She like sings throughout the years.
Mid?
Nah, it's peak.
The fandom wars.
Peak versus mid Shrek the musical.
Shrek is like one of those rare movie series though that like...
Well actually, wait, wasn't there one movie that people really didn't like?
I was going to say, all the sequels are all good.
Shrek 3, yeah, the third one.
Ripperoni.
Shrek, if you're listening to this...
I don't think it was bad, maybe.
Actually, I don't know.
Why are you guys like... What is this graffiti?
Minto time.
Did you guys have a good weekend?
What did you do this weekend?
Five is in the works.
Is it actually?
I'll see it... I'll believe it when I...
When I see a trailer.
Was a lazy weekend.
That's good though, that's not always bad, right?
Oh my god, furry fan art.
They drew their fursonas on the wall.
What are these?
I don't want to like get rid of them.
They're
like...
That's horses.
This is a horse.
This is not a horse.
It is a horse, not horses.
Just like Pokemon, okay.
Guys...
Maybe don't bring up Pokemon right now.
Minto streamed my birthday with Jabril!
Oh my gosh, curse name.
Wait, sorry.
Not curse name, sorry.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Jabril.
Happy birthday!
I don't know, okay.
I didn't read so much of everything that had come out.
Because, you know...
I also didn't look into the credibility of it all, you know?
So, I don't know.
But here's my take on if something like this is legitimate, you know?
Like...
And you know, if you're like, this is so unbased, whatever.
You know, it could be unbased, whatever.
But...
So it's like...
It'd be one thing if...
Because people are like...
There's like people arguing about it.
Being like, this is really cool mythos.
Like, you guys are just being babies about not understanding the mythos.
And this is why we'll never have a more adult-centered game.
But I'm just kind of like...
Wait.
Evan, is it your birthday too?
Sorry to double up birthday songs.
I turned 24 today, thanks for an entire year.
I mean, six months of amazing memories.
I can't wait to stick around with you in this amazing community.
Evan, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Evan and your kazoo covers.
Put some mite strips and hives today.
I've been working on rendering wax.
Tomorrow, I start on my Minto candle!
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to see.
Minto cleans properly.
Doki triggered OCD with this.
I mean, it's Doki.
I wonder if there will be a Metal Gear reference in Power Wash.
Since not even in your Pico Park 2 collab could you escape the notorious cardboard box.
I don't...
What if...
Oh my gosh.
They made a Metal Gear world?
That would be...
Like you...
You...
Power Wash Rex?
Actually, it would probably be...
Well, I don't know.
They would probably do like a...
I don't know if they would do 3 for Delta or...
Or what?
But anyway, I was talking about...
The...
The mythos, right?
Again, I see people being like...
Oh, you know, it's based off of this.
It's based off of that.
I think my...
My...
It's not my issue, but I'm just like...
Why didn't they release it then?
Like, why didn't they create stuff that's just like...
Oh, you know, this is a mythos about this creature.
And then...
And then, you know, someone playing the games could be like...
Oh my gosh, this moment happens in the games...
With this creature.
I wonder if it's influenced by the mythos.
But instead, they kind of like...
Keep it private for their own self?
It's...
It's weird.
Because it's so private.
So it makes me feel like they are putting stuff in the games...
With their...
Quote unquote mythos.
But it's only like an inside joke to them.
So I don't...
That's why it kind of annoys me.
Okay.
Writers do that all the time?
That doesn't make it okay, in my opinion.
I think you can have, you know...
Your own...
You know, stuff that you want to write about.
But like, also, why not, you know, share in it?
Like, with the audience.
I don't know.
It's just...
That's super normal for a writing process.
But I...
But then also...
I don't know.
Like I said, why don't you share that then?
With the audience.
Be like...
Here's like, you know...
The only thing I can relate it to is like...
How...
With the Harry Potter series...
She put out like books.
Like, there were extra books.
That were like...
What's it called?
That were like, this is the lore on...
This is like the book that they read in class.
You know, so you kind of get that context.
Like, why don't you put it out that?
Like that.
That's the only way I can...
That's the only like...
What's it called?
The only...
Comparison I can make.
But there's like...
Series all the time that were like...
Make a...
What's it called?
A...
Like extra books and stuff.
That are like, explaining lore and things like that.
Like I said, you know, I can be wrong.
Or rather, I don't think I'm wrong.
It's just my opinion.
Zun had a few lore books.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Don't let the weird Pokemon lore distract you...
From the fact that we have art of what...
Dugtrio looks like under the dirt.
Wait, actually...
I'm choosing my wording very carefully because...
I don't wanna say anything.
I don't wanna say any...
Specific words.
In case...
In case people are on the lookout.
And are like...
Someone mentioned it on...
Online.
I must take them down.
Went to Anime Impulse last weekend.
Had fun and bought some Minto merch.
Can not wait for the Minto Flash.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
I'm so happy there was Minto merch there.
Thank you!
RIP to all Typhlosion fans.
It's me.
I was a Typhlosion girly.
I mean, I still am.
But when I played the games and everything.
Always picked Cyndaquil.
Cyndaquil is my little guy.
Love that guy.
I love that guy.
So cute.
I haven't touched...
I don't know the last Pokemon game I...
I guess Sword and Shield was the last new one I did.
I think.
Shrek Doko.
Shrek!
What happened...
Here?
Do you think he's behind this window?
Shreketh...
Appeareth!
Oh god!
It's horrible!
Take... Oh, heed.
Why is only this part of the town so messed up?
I thought it said take weed also, okay?
That's why I was like kind of staring at it, like...
Okay, hold on.
Guys, we can make Shrek in the window.
We can... Wait...
We can make Shrek...
In the window.
Wait, hold on.
Get out my Shrek.
That's Shrek, it's not an alien.
This is him.
He's in the window.
There he... Oh my gosh, wait, it looks exactly...
Even the X... Even the cross eyes!
Mine had the cross eyes!
Oh my god, it looks exactly the same!
It looks exactly the same!
Save!
Trash.
Well, that's not very old timey.
Yee trash.
I'm sorry, yay trash.
Knights?
Knights Ruth!
No!
They left so much graffiti!
Knights.
Ruth!
You shall rue the day!
Knights.
Let's clean.
Yeah, what an exciting weekend!
There were so many things that happened.
So many things that happened.
And...
You know...
I guess there was a convention, Anime Impulse.
Next weekend is big too?
What's next weekend?
In old timey English, Y is actually a TH sound.
So in proper middle English, that's just the trash.
So it's actually TH sound, it's not yee trash.
So it's not yee old, it's the old?
No, it's gotta be yee old.
No way!
Sorry to ruin it.
I'm literally flushing my mind of this information.
Shhh...
Yee old trash.
No!
Brainwashing live on stream.
It's old timey, that's why they say yee.
You know?
Any good horror games lately?
Apparently Silent Hill 2 is pretty good.
Apparently.
I don't think I'll stream it.
But I want to play it.
Yeah.
As a Silent Hill fan.
Good transition, boss.
Yeah, it was...
Yeah.
What do you mean, eh?
I think, actually, I feel like people's expectations were just very low.
And so, because... I don't know, I can't say.
I haven't...
I haven't played it, so I don't know.
It could genuinely be good.
Which I don't think... I'm not saying that it's not.
Like, I'm just saying, like...
I think people's expectations were so low that...
When they got something way better than what they expected, they're like...
Game of the year!
You've watched streams?
No.
I haven't really watched anything...
Of it.
Farquad flower display.
Oh my god, my eyes.
This is a lot.
Did Doki ever get to Shrek's swamp?
Isn't there, like, several...
Levels you have to...
She did?
Oh, okay.
Are the trees fake or something?
Like, why?
Actually, do I have any money?
I have 200 money.
Shop.
Let's see.
Let's get maybe...
Some cleaning liquids.
Wait, there's new power washers.
Oh, I need stars?
Oh my god.
So much money.
I mean...
She did after losing her mind.
I do feel like expectations were low.
My only... My thing is I wonder how much was it...
Konami's direction and how much was Bloober's direction.
Bloober team's direction, but...
Hey, I mean...
If it's...
If it's a good remake, cool.
If it's a good remake, why not?
Shop.
Liquid.
What do you mean out of stock?
What?
So I can't get any assistance with this?
This is so messed up.
Liquid.
Guys, this is...
This is unrelated.
But I almost... I'm gonna have a confession right now.
I almost cancelled stream today.
I took a walk right before stream.
It was so nice outside.
I was like, what if I just...
What if I just said, sorry guys, I gotta walk.
I gotta...
I just gotta... I gotta go outside.
I gotta take a walk.
It was so nice.
But also, I just... I have a lot to do.
A lot to finish.
I'm kind of really stressed about...
My debut.
I'm hoping everything will be...
Done in time, but...
I'm hoping everything will be done in time.
Ashes!
Can you power wash my brain next, please?
I have worms up there.
Oh, you and me both, girl.
You got this.
It's really, you know...
It's less me and more so...
People working on things for me.
Which, you know...
I don't want to...
Put so much stress on them.
So if they're just like...
Minto is not gonna get done.
I'm like, aw man, we'll have to delay it.
We'll have to delay it a couple days or so.
Hopefully not.
You know, usually...
I would just plan it for any...
Whatever day.
Since it's Halloween...
And if it's not on Halloween...
I think it'll...
Quote-unquote ruin the effect maybe a little bit.
But...
I don't know.
Feeling a little stressed about it.
Hopefully it all works out though.
We'll be here regardless.
Thank you.
If it's not on Halloween, guys...
We'll just pretend it's Halloween, okay?
Or all my theming will...
Be for naught.
If you say the Halloween a few days later...
My Halloween will be a few days later.
What would be so bad about extending Halloween anyway?
That actually sounds like the best thing ever.
To me.
Maybe.
But of course I'll give you guys a heads up.
If that were to occur.
Because I don't want someone to be like...
You know how some people can be.
They're like, I take off work for this.
And I'm like...
Why?
It's just a stream.
Can you tell me I'm a rockstar?
Hey now, hey now, hey now.
Not everybody can be a rockstar.
What kind of rockstar things have you done?
Huh?
Have you...
Have you had strippers on your party bus?
That sounds like a rockstar thing.
Have you...
Have you broken a guitar string?
That's a rockstar thing.
I played guitar hero once.
Impressive.
You're a rockstar.
No.
Have you had strippers on your band bus, Ms. Mint?
No, and I'm not claiming to be a rockstar.
I'm not asking for someone...
Okay.
If I tell you you're a rockstar...
It's because you're...
You're cosplaying.
You know?
Cute rockstar cosplay.
If Snake and Minto Minto merged, what month would they be?
Month?
What month would we be?
I changed my mind.
Getting degraded like this is even better than validation.
Degrade me more.
Hurt me more, Minto.
Oh dear Christ.
Did we awaken something in you?
This wisp had an awakening.
Hallelujah.
Wait, isn't that a Shrek song?
Was it Hallelujah in Shrek?
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
How do I spell it?
Shrek Film!
Oh my gosh.
Shrek Film.
Oh my God.
Here we go.
The baffled king composing Hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
Wait, I can't see the lyrics if I do this.
Your faith was strong, but you needed proof.
You saw her bathing on the roof.
Her beauty in the moonlight overthrew you.
She tied you to a...
She cut your hair.
And from your lips she drew the Hallelujah.
This is you when you realize that you like to be decorated.
Hallelujah.
Maybe I've been here before.
I know this room.
I've walked this floor.
I used to live alone before I knew you.
I've seen your flag on the marble arch.
Love is not a victory march.
It's cold and it's all broken.
Hallelujah.
There was
a time you'd let me know.
What's really going on below.
But now you never show it to me.
Do you?
I moved in you.
The holy dove was moving too.
And every breath we drew was Hallelujah.
Is this ever a song really about you?
Maybe
there's a God above.
And all I ever learned from love.
Was how to shoot at someone who outdrew ya.
And it's not a cry you can hear at night.
It's not somebody who's seen the light.
It's cold and it's all broken.
Hallelujah.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, what if we just so naturally, casually fit in all the...
Wait!
You talked about All-Star earlier.
Dang it.
I completely forgot to sing it.
That's the finale though.
All-Star has to be the finale, okay guys?
Can't just be up here.
Didn't want to interrupt the song, but one time in Vegas I got stripper's autograph and taking the party bus?
And a limo too!
But never all at once.
Kinki, every time you explain a story you really just live up to your name.
I'm telling you.
Shrek used to own the Hallelujah space in my brain until I saw the Donkey Kong remix.
Kong-Hallelujah.
I need to know more.
Oh my gosh, there's birds.
There's the castle.
Wow, it looks like a modern day game console.
Where is this version?
I can never find the right version for karaoke.
The one that I just played?
I got it from Kara-Fun.
It's one of my favorite songs and he made it funny and adorable and amazing all at once.
No!
What are you talking about?
Thank you.
I'll sing it properly later.
I'll sing it properly later when we...
When we are... When we are here.
When we finish cleaning.
We must clean!
We must clean.
Theacross!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
You freak.
Making me sing a... First you asked me to degrade you.
And then you make me sing a song about sex.
You freak!
Me until learning... Finding out in real time that the song is freaky.
BigAnimer!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
I feel like that's me with a lot of songs though sometimes.
I often like... Love songs for mostly the melody.
And then I'll like... Sing the song.
Or... I don't know.
Sometimes the lyrics just don't process in my brain.
And then I sing it and I'm like... Whoa, wait a second.
There's something strange about this one.
I don't think he made you degrade him.
You're right.
I wanted to do that.
Keep doing it then.
Stop being so freaky!
What's wrong with you guys?
Chat, you guys... Chat always gets too comfortable with the streamer, I swear.
You become too comfortable and you're just like... I can just ask her.
You ask as if... It's just like when you ask someone like...
Hey, can you go pick this up at the store for me?
Oh, you're going over there?
Can you grab this for me?
Oh, hey, you're streaming?
Can you degrade me?
Like it's just like... Oh, hey, while you're doing that...
Can you call me a nasty, ugly piece of shit?
Thanks!
You guys have to... Please, have more dignity.
Where is your dignity?
I say as a hypocrite.
Center display floor still... Oh, I see.
Okay, there we go.
Like streamer, like chat.
Honorless wisp.
My dignity is currently boneless.
You guys...
I fell asleep like right as I started it last night, but I started...
Not the next book, but I discovered that there is another book...
Of the milking farm, but from the guy's point of view.
So...
But I started it last night and immediately fell asleep.
So I have nothing to say.
Dignity?
What VTuber is that?
Oh god, not again.
What do you mean?
You're not the one listening to it, it's me.
Dignity is overrated.
I know some people... Sometimes my friends are just like...
Mint, how do you handle people talking to you like this?
But honestly, I think it's...
There's something very special about someone being their true self.
And you know, if you're comfortable here...
You know, I'm not saying it's like the best thing ever, but like...
You know...
How do I put this down?
Wait, how do I put it down?
Freaky phantom.
Why are you guys so freaky?
Can I not lean it against the tree?
Wait, oh yeah, I can't lean it against the tree.
That kind of sucks.
Is that Kermy or Cermy?
Welcome to my membership!
Thank you!
Chat reflects the streamer.
Half a year abandoning my dignity.
Something about being cringe, something about being free.
If you can't handle me at my freakiest...
You don't deserve me at my phantomest.
One second, there we go.
Oh hey, Mint, can you compliment yourself?
What a strange request.
Why are you so weird?
Now this is real torture.
What, these things?
I'm not gonna do them right now, because I hate doing...
In between the little spokes and wheels and everything...
And all the little gears and everything.
So annoying!
Do it!
You can't make me!
You actually can't make me.
It's great watching people make their true selves, like this stream.
Every time Ocelot is on screen.
Yeah.
Six months of being hated.
Yippee!
Lost in the story, thanks for the 20k!
I can hear that your court of spray-a-ton has a large round table...
Where every knight has a seat to discuss the orders of the day.
How did Lord Farquaad get my number?
Duloc has a larger table with just one seat.
Mine.
He makes everybody sit in his lap.
He's so weird.
Bag, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
He matched you on Tinder.
Oh my gosh, a rooster!
Goodbye, bird.
Do you think there's anything under there?
No?
Okay.
Trash can.
It's complete.
Okay.
Yeet trash.
I'm in the... Hello!
Hello!
Alright guys, I want to do my own vandalism.
I want to do my own vandalism.
Let's see.
What should we do?
What should we write?
Are Shrek spoilers allowed in this stream?
I've only seen Shrek 1 and 2.
But I know some spoilers.
BB.
Why do you guys want me to write BB?
BB?
You should watch the Shrek musical.
My favorite line is, this ass of mine is asinine.
It's pretty good.
Death Stranding, baby.
Okay.
Ink Phantom!
Oh my gosh.
You sound like my cousin.
Thanks for the gifted!
Hold on.
Freak was here.
I did it.
I did it dirty.
You guys.
I was naughty.
Oh my gosh.
I'm a delinquent.
You did a cleanie.
Yeah.
Oh, Vince, you're so bad.
Oh my gosh.
Was the Lorax also Dreamworks?
The song, How Bad Can I Be?
I've never seen it, so...
No?
What was it?
Was it Illumination?
It's Illumination?
I think we got the whole...
Cart?
Wait.
There we go.
I think now we have the whole cart.
I think.
And probably Ding Dong and Ditch when she was younger.
No, I...
I was like...
So...
Like...
A stupidly good kid.
I was like...
No...
I was safety...
I was like a safety monitor at my school.
And I got promoted to head safety monitor.
Like, I...
Was very like...
You know, never get in trouble, never do anything.
The most I did was...
Jump in ditches because I thought I could go to see Inuyasha.
Oh, thanks for the brain!
Oh, I missed the name.
I missed the name!
I'm sorry, thank you for the brain!
Sorry, it's...
White on white.
Stupid YouTuber.
It's always the most behaved ones.
Well, you know.
And then I discovered Newgrounds.
And I still was a good kid.
I just went on Newgrounds.
Played things I shouldn't have played and saw things I shouldn't have seen.
But I think I turned out okay.
Oh, Nyaru!
Thanks for the brain!
Ducky, thanks for the gift!
The MNF games.
Yeah.
Now you can just get that kind of stuff on Steam.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I bought Orc Massage.
And I will play it in my free time.
I will not have Doki Bird calling me...
Less...
Less of a freak than her.
Because I hadn't played it.
And I have all my... Oh, what's this?
Information board.
Oh.
Welcome to Duloc.
Interact with the information stand lever.
Does it say poo?
Oh, poo.
Doki is just coping.
She's surprisingly safe compared to you.
Information...
Does this work?
Where is my song?
Oh my God!
Oh my God, even the guy in jail.
Wash your... Ass.
That's the only part of the song I remember.
Do I have to watch the whole thing and then they'll sing to me?
Oh, sorry.
Face!
I remember.
I'm not making it raunchier.
It's literally Shrek.
They do that all on their own.
They don't need my help.
What parts of this... Oh my gosh, there's still unclean people.
Can I get in here?
Oh my gosh, I can join!
Nevermind, I can't join.
Oh, here we go.
Oh my gosh, how am I supposed to clean the back of this?
Puppet Sage, good.
Little puppet people, you OK?
Everything good?
Wait, here?
Oh my gosh.
OK.
Do you think it's better now?
Let's try it.
Press the button.
I mean, pull the lever.
It's the most...
Disappointing thing.
That's me right now.
No way!
It has to be more clean?
Will it actually sing it though?
You sure?
OK.
More clean, more clean.
More clean.
We'll get the whole thing, we'll get the whole thing.
Even the ground around it.
It'll be so clean you can lick it.
You can eat off of it.
It's perfect.
Chai never lies.
This is the most important part.
You guys, if you're lying...
I might cry for real, OK?
So you're telling the truth, right?
It'll play the song?
What's that mean?
It's a yes or no question.
OK.
If you guys are lying, I'm gonna have to sing Hallelujah again, maybe.
Because it's supposed to be a sad song.
What other Shrek songs are there?
I meant to look this up before stream, and I got...
I was busy dealing with some stuff.
Oh, I'm sorry about there not being a schedule up yet for this week.
Hopefully tonight, I'm waiting on confirmation for stuff this weekend.
Accidentally in love.
I know.
And then I saw her face.
I'm a believer.
Not a trace.
I'm in love.
YMCA?
Is that in Shrek?
Were you the one who messaged Doki and asked her if she was having fun while she was playing Orc Massage?
No!
I don't think I've ever seen her... I don't think I...
I've seen her with her game...
Like...
Whatever's on Discord, you know?
But mine are on, so if I'm playing it...
Maybe I'll get some messages.
We'll see.
It looks so clean!
Oh my god, my eyes.
Speedy fire!
Thanks for 6 months!
And now, the Orc Massage also has mermaid girls in case you're interested, so...
There's more.
Information...
It looks 100%?
Oh wait.
Some panels are not 100%?
Some panels are still dirty.
Will you give us a video essay?
It's a lot of work.
Can't I just tell you about it?
Oh wait, maybe it's done.
We need...we need like a...
We need this.
Oh there's a ladder right there.
Why can't I put it against it though?
It denies me my right!
Orc Massage is alright, but it hasn't had an update in over a year.
I hope the devs haven't...Wait, but...
It said there were mermaids now.
Is that not a recent update?
There we go.
Okay.
Easy.
Easy now.
We are such professionals.
It's frequent enough that it's not considered abandoned.
Oh wait, maybe we are good now.
I think so.
Okay, let's try it one more time.
Did I miss?
Is every little puppet clean?
Clean!
Huh?
I'm not crying yet!
It's...my eyes are just a little glassy.
Because I'm so glassy.
Woooo!
On the grass, find your shoes, wipe your face!
Duloc is...Duloc is the perfect place!
Oh my God, it took a picture of us even.
Not rigged.
Yippee!
I knew it would play, you guys!
Gosh, you scared me for a second.
I thought you had lied to me or something.
But you would never...
You would never do that to me.
We've never lied once.
I know!
Yeah, we would never lie to you or bully you.
You'd never bully me.
I don't even think I bully you.
I have the power here.
I don't think you could even bully me.
It's my stream.
I can do whatever I want.
I can blip you guys on your heads.
I can make you guys literally have all the blood rush to your heads right now.
You can't do that to me because I...
am a ghost.
And I'm filled with ectoplasm.
You're not gonna get me with that, Murphy.
I'm stronger.
Let's just bait.
Calling me cute is the least...
Is the bait is the least...
Is the most...
I mean, it's the...
It's the one that is the most lazy.
You literally begged for mercy yesterday.
During the Vulcan fight, you're not Vulcan.
You're not Vulcan.
Wait, were you self-inserting?
Were you like, I'm Vulcan, so...
She was talking to me.
It's not him, it should've been me.
Hi, I'm Vulcan.
No, you're Tonkin.
You're so cute.
No!
Lazy attempt.
Try some new material.
I'm sick of hearing that one.
Cute.
No!
Think anybody lives here?
I live here.
Welcome to my home.
Vulcan is nuts.
What does that mean?
Calling her cute works, she was clearly flustered.
No, I wasn't!
I just don't know how to say words.
Adorkable.
Oh no, you're just reminding me of Mothman now.
Adorable even.
No, stop.
When I hear adorable right now, I'm thinking of Mothman.
Please.
If you want, I'll draw a demonstration of his folds.
Chuu, thank you.
Minto is the cutest.
Stop!
You're talented and a gamer and you sing so, so great.
I'll have you know that I was a chat all along.
Clicks in the morning.
No!
Minto, adorable.
Stop.
You're pretty good.
See, that's not even...
That's not bullying.
But it makes my brain unwell.
Wait, what's happening here?
There we go.
It makes my brain unwell.
Okay, so let me find a dirty wall.
Okay, so Mothman...
He's an innie.
This is his body.
He's got little legs.
Actually, I don't know what his legs are like.
Because he doesn't wear... He can't wear pants.
Okay?
And he...
I don't know how it works though.
He's just got like a little...
And it's vacuum sealed.
He's pantsless.
But she makes him wear pants.
She's like, you're gonna wear pants right now.
She's like, you gotta wear pants.
Right now.
We're putting these pants on you right now.
Oh my gosh.
It's got a little hole.
And he's also covered in moth dust.
Which gets all over him.
You're funny, charming... Stop!
What is this?
This is not a compliment hour!
Going back to the side.
We'll meet the mothman later.
You challenged us.
I didn't challenge anything!
You have no power.
But you're so small.
Praise her until she's homeless.
Watching your streams helps me get back into writing and painting.
Minis!
Thank you for making such a funny and entertaining stream.
You're a great singer.
Thank you!
Minis.
Are they hotter than Mothra?
I don't think so.
Gosh, I just can't get over how much I hated the characters in that book though.
Get cherished, ghost freak.
No, please.
Mint is cute.
Why?
That's how you know.
She means business.
Even the no is angry.
Even the no.
Even the no has to tell you no.
Thank you for being here with us.
You're okay, I guess.
Yeah, whatever.
Being...
Why are you guys...
Why are you guys so...
Wholesome sometimes.
It's not very becoming.
No more...
I ban wholesomeness from this chat.
I ban it, I ban it.
It's a balancing act.
You sure?
Yeah, I'm positive.
Oh my god, it looks like we're in the circus.
Do you feel at home?
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thanks for coming to the meet and greet too, Cornelius.
Oh my god.
Can I leave this city?
It's making you guys weird.
Can I get out of here?
It's making you guys strange.
It's the air or something.
What's happening?
I couldn't find another song.
I had this in my...
In my, like, immediate folder.
So I just picked it.
I was like, oh, you know, maybe people will...
Watch this and want to, like, chill out...
After work or something today.
So, I don't know.
And it's just kind of matched the vibes of a power wash sim.
Because it's kind of a chill, you know.
Thank you for playing this.
Cleansing my eyes from Doki.
Just doing the bare minimum and leaving dirt everywhere.
Give me an aneurysm.
lol
I don't want to know what her...
What her room looks like.
Aisle sidewalk, there's more?
Oh my gosh.
Oh wait.
Okay, this is the same.
But my room is kind of a mess right now too.
Because I've been moving stuff around.
Oh my gosh.
Today I got a sticker notebook.
Like a sticker binder.
Kind of.
And...
I was able to put most of my stickers in.
Some of them didn't fit.
So I'm really sad.
But I finally got one.
For all my, like...
Metal gear sticker sheets.
That I've been buying recently.
What are you, 10?
10, what do you mean?
There's like...
What are you talking about?
People sell Vtuber stickers all the time.
They sell like...
Stickers for video games and stuff.
Like...
I have so many.
I have stickers of my favorite idols.
I have so many stickers.
And I don't want to just put them...
And not be able to use them anymore afterwards.
It hurts!
Minto is super cute.
Stop!
Your streams help me with life.
Why are you guys so...
Wholesome right now.
It's always nice to hear your voice.
And to know you're doing well.
Am I doing well?
I don't think so.
You guys, I'm brain rotted.
Well is...
It's like...
You're doing...
Quote-unquote well.
Doing quote-unquote well.
How do you even do the bare minimum in this game?
Like, get it until it recharges?
Or not recharge...
Does the...
Mothman!
He had big ol' long arms.
Oh my gosh, it was so funny too.
Because sometimes she'd be like...
And he had really long fingers.
She made a point of saying that.
She would be like, aren't you...
Aren't you gonna kidnap me from a bridge or something?
And he's like, that's just an urban legend.
I'm like...
What even is life if you don't have things you like too much?
True!
I worry sometimes that like...
You know...
The day that you like...
Whenever you stop watching Vtubers...
You become uninterested in Vtubers...
That like, you regret having all...
If you bought Vtuber merch or whatever...
You regret...
Not liking it or you're just like...
Oh man, like...
I donated so much money to...
To those streamer girls.
I should've saved it for something else.
I regret not...
I regret it.
I think about that...
Somewhat often.
I feel like I'm like...
Man, I have to make it...
Yee-oh!
The souvenir shoppy!
I feel like I'm like...
I hope that I can make...
You know, even if it's just like a short time...
I hope I can like...
Make it worth it, you know?
And you're just like...
Then later on you're not like...
Oh my gosh, I have to get rid of all this merchandise...
What do I do?
Like give it to a...
Donate it to a thrift store?
Nobody wants it?
lol
Garble!
Oh, Binto is not only cute...
But seeing how hard she always works is genuinely inspiring.
Stop!
19 year old hag love.
I'll eat the merch.
Okay, that's a good idea actually.
I used to be a brony...
So I cast aside all my regrets long ago.
Oh my gosh.
I thought I was gonna say...
I cast aside all my merch long ago.
Never regret.
What do you do with all your...
I don't regret my MLP merch.
Oh my gosh, we have multiple bronies.
Brony to Vtuber pipeline reel?
I had a pony song stuck in my head the other day.
It was the one...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
It was when that girl was gonna get married...
But the chrysalis queen took over her body or whatever.
And they had like that little duet.
And it's like...
It goes way harder than it should've.
This day is going to be perfect.
The one that I dreamed.
The dream since I was small.
That one!
Vtubers have helped me more than real people at times.
With the sheer joy they display playing games and hanging out with friends.
And hopefully you can also make a lot of friends.
Through...
You know.
What's this one?
Oh my gosh.
This shop is probably like the ye olde freak shop.
Bread.
Someone who has spent money on merch in the past and brings back good memories.
Close enough.
Yeah, close enough.
I'll take it.
Ye olde freaky bread shop.
Even when I fall out of a series I try to keep like...
One thing, you know?
Cause I'm...
Say there's an anime.
Anime seasons end.
So it's just like...
There's some anime that like...
I will...
Forever just be ranting and raving about that series.
But if there's one that I just liked and I bought a couple things from it If I don't like it so much anymore I'll like usually...
I have actually a bag of stuff that I have to bring to Japan with me next time to sell at Mandarake.
But like I'll...
I'll try to keep at least one thing.
Because I'm like...
The most things that I like the most.
Because I'll be like...
You know, this series once...
You know, I liked it enough to...
Buy stuff, you know?
So...
Mandrake, let's go.
Yeah...
I had to watch MLP with my Wii sister.
It was a decent show and opinion compared to...
It is!
It's actually decent, right?
Why not make a lot of enemies?
Into friends.
I expected better of you.
It's enemies to lovers.
Enemies to friends?
I don't want it.
Oh, goodbye Mothman.
Enemy series is different from Vtubers?
Like this way?
Have you ever regretted or gotten rid of your idol merch?
No.
Oh, well...
Okay.
Once.
I'm gonna be very...
Bare in my mint coffee shop.
And...
It was an idol that...
She was my...
First ever Kamiyoshi, actually.
And I...
Loved her.
I loved her so much.
Oh my gosh.
My first ever Kamiyoshi.
That's a big deal, right?
And then...
Some like...
Not so good stuff...
Came out about her.
In the news.
And I was like...
Really...
Seeing her now makes me so upset.
You know?
So I'm just like...
Like her image...
Was ruined.
So that...
But I feel like that's a really...
That's like a specific case, right?
Like, you know...
That's like...
That's like a specific...
Thing.
But anyone else...
Of course not.
I've never even...
Even my Oshis that have all graduated and stuff...
Like ten years ago, I've never gotten rid of their stuff.
They're streamers I've watched since childhood.
Oh my gosh, Shawn, you're a baby.
Little baby.
Specific and reasonable.
Yeah, right?
Like, it's different.
But...
For other idols and everything...
No.
So, okay, I get it.
But I don't know.
I feel like...
Sometimes I'm just like, you know...
Not everyone thinks with the same brain as me.
So for me, I'm just like, I could never...
My Oshi is my Oshi.
But I don't know if you think that way, right?
I don't know.
I don't know!
Did you see the lilac art with...
Ofuda instead of the Sankakukin?
Can that be canon?
This has done permanent damage.
I feel like I get more of...
Fan art of Goth Minto than...
Than anything else!
Permanent damage to the Wisp community.
We have to have different mint flavors, right?
Since I'm...
Since I'm mint green, usually...
Then if I'm purple...
I can be lilac.
What other things?
Maybe blue could be like...
Aqua or something.
And then red can be like...
Chili.
Yellow can be...
Orange can be pumpkin.
We need one called Spearmint.
Why?
Let's skip yellow.
I can put banana.
Banana, banana.
What's wrong with yellow?
What do you have against yellow?
Spearmint is just mint with a knife.
So true.
Lemon?
Oh my gosh, wait, I can be lemon with yellow?
Yeah, lemon.
What other colors are there?
Pink?
What would pink be?
I'm a new fan...
But I hear a lot of people talking about chili.
Chili, eh?
Chili...
Chili came out one time.
Actually, two times.
One time publicly on Twitter.
Mojito mint.
I'm not a flavor mint.
I have some Brazilian mint in the future.
What do you mean in the future?
If you can get enough colors, you can make super sentai mint- That sounds awesome!
Chili, my kamiyoshi.
I miss her.
What the hell, Lily?
I'm right here.
No, chili came out for...
I think it was April Fool's.
She said some bad words.
She said some...
She was not very polite.
Some horrible things.
If you think I hate you...
You say this already.
Bring her back!
Mint is cute, but lilac is hot.
So it compliments...
Yeah.
She has no sex appeal, but lilac...
That
girl...
She's making me want to act up.
Mint?
Who?
Who's that?
She's gone.
Yeah, I get it.
You guys are so simple.
I'm not even reading that.
I don't even want to read it.
Wait, can we go on the roof?
Wait, do you think Shrek is back here?
Oh no, there's an invisible wall.
They're keeping us from him.
Read it!
Please read it.
Why?
Read it.
No!
I don't even want to read it.
I don't even know.
It's cringe in the best way.
Read it, coward!
Read it with a British accent.
Okay, that might be the only way I get it.
Read it, coward.
Don't give up the satisfaction.
Made lilac.
I am...
I offer thee this pink super...
Pink like...
The highlights in your hair.
Okay, first of all, you're...
Colorblind.
And like the love in my kokoro.
Don't tell Mitt.
Wait, oh gosh.
Okay, there we go.
How can you say...
Like the highlights in my hair...
When I'm literally lilac?
There's no out of...
There's no pink!
Plus two.
Stop it.
I think that means a good thing.
Don't stop, don't give him the satisfaction.
Those are some big highlights.
That's like your balls.
Those are some...
You have a lot of...
You know?
I'm so tired.
I can't wait for the day when I can just...
Leave the internet and have nobody...
Perceive me anymore.
I can't wait for this day.
Okay, turquoise.
Maybe one day.
Okay.
How long have I been...
Cleaning this place?
An hour and a half, okay.
None of us can escape.
You're here forever.
Why?
It's such like a...
Perfect line, but they...
I would hate to live here.
Then your neighbor is just like...
She hates us for sure.
This is what you wanted, isn't it?
Isn't this what you wanted?
What's the next area?
Is the next area the swamp?
Please say yes.
Wait, actually...
I'm trying to remember.
With Spongebob, we first had...
We had like...
The crab...
No, not the crabby patty.
Or, not, uh, Krusty Krab.
No, it's not!
Swamp is third?
Wait, don't tell me what the second one is.
Don't tell me what the second one is.
Welcome to my bishopancule!
I can't reach.
Oh, this area sucks.
Can I...
Wood cleaner?
Stone cleaner?
Multipurpose?
Is this a multipurpose?
This is stone.
Wait, hold on.
There we go.
Never forget the clam bucket.
Stone.
Oh my gosh, it's working.
Wait, what's this?
Stone!
Wait, did I...
I put it on, right?
No, oh.
Nevermind.
Let me, let me use it.
Why won't it let me use it?
Why won't it let me buy anything?
Why is it so cruel?
It's a different nozzle.
Is the color swapped because you're trying to match your Kamiyoshi this Halloween?
Oh, I just felt like being a little goth, you know.
I'm back!
Did you miss me?
Don't I look so refreshing after seeing a color swap palette?
You're just like, wow.
Seeing this bright, refreshing mint is just so...
It's healing for my soul.
Don't you just think that?
Who are you?
Oh, hey, mint.
Where's Lilac?
It's like when you have a game and a fighting game character and there's a...
There's a palette swap.
Isn't that so exciting?
You're just like, oh, I like the color swap, the palette swap, but of course the original is my favorite.
Right?
The original just suits it the best.
Mint is healing for my soul always.
I mod my color palette.
Waiting for the made lemon DLC.
One day I'll have the whole rainbow, I'll show you guys, okay?
Just a little bit more.
Mods, ban that roaming tuna guy.
Mods, get his ass.
Who are you?
That's mean.
Lilac is my Yoshi, but also so is the mint phantom.
Right?
Guys, don't forget about me.
Don't forget about me.
You're gonna make me cry again.
What if there's like someone looking through the window?
They were horrified that we were like...
Looking through their window.
Gosh, I'm getting mothman flashbacks again.
Waiting for the phantom sentai team.
The sun.
Open up.
Click, click, click.
Oh my gosh, there's a sexy lady in here.
Click, clack.
Chirp, chirp.
I don't know why she made the mothman chirp.
I know he's got wings and stuff, but he's not a bird.
Moths don't chirp.
I found the author's Twitter last night.
That lady is just freaky.
She's so freaky.
She has a Patreon even.
And like one of the Patreon tiers is like...
A milker at the milk farm or something.
Certified freak.
She had a tweet that said that.
She was like, certified freak.
Seven days a week.
You could be a milker in her...
Actually, that's one of the tiers.
Is you can be a character.
You can be...
A character.
Do I rewatch Mirai Nikki or another?
I like the opening for Mirai Nikki so much.
It was like you're an insert character next to some other character whose name I didn't recognize.
And I was like, what if that character sucks?
Please do it.
If I do it, you guys have to read the book.
If I do it... Hold on, let me see.
What was her name?
Cambrick Creek.
O.C.M.
Nacosta.
Patreon.
Let's see.
Sorry Mint, I can't read.
I can't read!
You can, you can!
So, for $10 a month you can be a milking assistant at the morning glory farm.
This is the next book.
The next tier is intake at Moonblooded Breeding Clinic.
That's the one I told you about if you listened during the Metal Gear stream.
It's about werewolves.
And then for $25 a month you can be Elvish Country Club.
I don't know what that one is.
It's $50 a month.
You can be the autumn consort.
It says I'll make you a seasonal guest star alongside Tate.
In every Cambrick Creek story.
I don't know who Tate is.
And you get...
You get a premium swag book box.
Signed physical copy of a published work.
I don't want this.
Early access ebook.
The good stuff.
I don't know what that means.
You've got mail.
Discount in the Etsy shop.
What did she sell?
What did she sell on Etsy?
Polls and gratitude discord access.
Oh my god, there's a discord?
Discord?
What's the good stuff?
The VC in there must be insane.
What if we like took it over?
We had a Wisp invasion.
Could we match their freak?
Honestly?
I'm not so sure.
Honestly, I think we'd be in trouble.
Where is the rest of it?
Please.
Please be clean.
Where else...
Would we want to match it?
I think...
Guys, I'm afraid that we would be like...
Look at us.
Invading this freak's discord.
Look at these guys.
They...
They're so into the minotaurs and balls.
And then it would be funny.
And then we'd be like...
We're reading every book.
And then we would have discussions.
And then it would become serious.
I feel like...
Then we'd be like...
Oh no.
We'd be having serious discussion about like...
Stuff, you know?
I feel like it wouldn't be...
A joke anymore.
Oh, finally.
We cleaned a single roof.
Got it.
Rooftop.
Completed.
In the book club stream.
I think you guys actually want me to go insane.
I think you guys actually want me to suffer.
Yes.
At least you're honest.
At least.
I hate cleaning the rooftops.
How many are there?
One.
I guess just the two.
Okay.
Pick up.
Go over here.
Literature club.
Honestly, why doesn't...
Doki should start one and then she can call it the actual Doki Doki literature club.
No copyright.
But I don't think Doki can read.
I don't think she can read.
It's a distressingly good idea.
She can't read.
Guys, it's no good.
We have to stop the idea as soon as it was born.
We've already hit our major hurdle.
The most important aspect of the book club.
Doki's inability to read.
She's too birdbrained.
Audiobooks exist.
Yeah, that's how I get through mine.
Just listen to the audiobook and fall asleep.
But again, the birdbrain.
Doki Doki learns how to read club.
It's a work in progress.
The title is a work in progress.
One day.
Do you ever have freaky dreams from your books?
Like, sexy dreams?
I just have freaky dreams in general.
Not sexy dreams.
But like, things about...
Oh gosh, I had one recently.
I did have one last night that I was like...
Like I had all these...
I grew all these... I had all these boils on my face.
I don't think that has anything to do with minotaurs.
Junji Ito?
Maybe!
Oh my gosh, I've been hearing about the Uzumaki anime, right?
I've never read erotica stuff like Fifty Shades of Grey.
But for a beginner-slash-baby-step, I recommend a series called Alia Sometimes Hides Her Feelings in Russian.
Oh!
Wait, the light novel!
Wait, there's spicy scenes in that?
I have a... I have a...
An acrylic stand of that character before the anime came out.
Because I like the artist...
Who does the... What's it called?
The character designer?
Why can't... Why can't it work here?
Why can't I put the ladder here?
So annoying.
Just put it on the ground.
How do I get rid of it?
There.
Wait, no.
That's always there.
The sister is more popular.
I have a lot of dreams about school.
When I first started streaming, I had many...
Dreams about, like, accidentally leaving my...
Like, my stream going.
Oh, Tori!
Thank you for the raid!
Hello everybody, my name is Mint Fanto!
I'm a ghost maid.
We're in Shrek Land.
Like the Vtuber anime?
Yes, similar.
I would, like, have dreams that...
My stream would be, like, going on my phone.
And I would go to sleep.
And then, I would, like, talk in my sleep.
Or fart.
And that...
It was all caught on camera.
And I had, like, legitimate nightmares about it.
Oh my gosh.
One time I had a dream that I...
Sent the wrong link of a YouTube video to chat.
And everybody made fun of me for it.
I was like, check out this video.
And then it led to another video.
And everyone was just like, oh my gosh.
You watch this?
So...
This is so embarrassing.
I can't believe you're a fan of that.
I was like, no, no, no.
I didn't...I wasn't watching that.
This is so embarrassing.
And I had a dream about it.
And everybody made fun of me.
I had a dream...
Oh, I'd have a nightmare if you accidentally started a stream with your spicy audiobooks.
The lady who narrates them too is just so...
Well, she was the ones...
The cambric ones.
The monster ones.
Oh my goodness.
How did I get up here?
We would never make fun of you.
Really?
What if it was like...
What if it was like something really cringe?
Like a Jake Paul video.
Or Logan Paul.
I don't know which one is different.
Which?
Okay, then I would see!
He would make fun of me.
But I don't even watch them, so don't get it twisted.
That was just an example.
That was just an example, okay?
Wait, wait.
This place...
It's another shop.
Okay.
This is the old freak shop for real.
Let's get some Starbees.
Dang.
It could be...
Freaky coffee, yeah.
It's so...
It's so delicious, it's freaky.
You know?
One of those types of situations.
It's PSL season.
Oh my gosh.
Absolutely, I even got...
Well, I don't get the pumpkin spice latte.
But I...
A coffee place by me has like a different type of pumpkin drink.
I went out and got it today.
I was like, I'm craving this.
I'm gonna have it.
So I went and got it.
Oh, you're a quiet one, aren't you?
Much like myself.
Lord Farquaad.
What else you got to say?
Yeah, I'm a mint of few words.
I pride myself on speaking only when absolutely necessary.
Using the fewest words that is possible used to articulate my train of thought.
That's why he used so few words to say that whole sentence.
I know people are just like, oh my gosh, the pumpkin spice latte is like so overrated.
But also, I hate those people.
Because...
Why can't I just get something because it's delicious, you know?
Oh, no more, no less.
Just the absolute minimum number of words to get across the brilliance of the idea itself.
Wow, pumpkin spice latte is so good!
Oh wait, hold on, my chat froze.
What makes it spice?
I've never had it.
I know sometimes they put like cinnamon and stuff.
And then the pumpkin taste.
And what is it?
It's a nutmeg, I think.
It is nutmeg.
My YouTube crashed.
Give me a moment, I'm so sorry.
Saying good things are overrated is lame.
I just think they just don't want people to be happy and enjoy.
You know?
Just enjoy.
Who cares if it's a popular thing?
No fun allowed.
It doesn't even have pumpkin in it, it doesn't?
Well...
It tastes good.
It tastes yummy.
Just the spice.
Oh, it's the spice that makes it taste like a pumpkin.
Oh well, who cares?
Oh my gosh, sorry guys.
My YouTube is so broken right now.
I can't see anything.
Oh, there we go.
Pumpkin is pretty much tasteless.
I wouldn't say that.
Maybe it also depends on...
Depends on where you get it from, right?
Pirate505 I know a place where they actually put pumpkin pulp in it.
Tastes surprisingly nice.
Depends on where you get it from.
Depends on where you get it.
Guys, I'm so sick of this area.
We have a lot.
We have so much left.
It feels like we're never gonna make it.
We're never gonna make it, guys.
I'm sick of Duloc.
Why is this the first level?
This should be the last level.
It's humongous.
60% still to go.
Oh my gosh.
Pumpkin spice.
Still is good.
Yeah!
I realized I didn't get the summer merch when I thought I did.
I died on the inside.
No!
Can't wait for your 3.0 model.
Thank you!
Thanks Onix!
Me too, I'm so excited.
I hope everything gets done in time though.
I'm stressing out.
Who the heck is Hugh?
The guy that owns this place.
I worked at Starbs for years.
And every year, there were dudes being jerks about people drinking PSL.
Anyway, I get mine with a little bit of chai syrup.
Yeah!
With chai syrup.
It's so good.
Yummy, yummy.
Enjoy your drinks, everybody.
If you like it, enjoy it.
If they just served it all year round...
Nobody would get so...
Feral for it.
Speaking of feral, I'm kind of hungry.
I didn't have dinner.
I thought I would be okay.
Since I had a late breakfast.
And then I finished eating the breakfast right before stream.
Hmm...
Maybe I'll grab a snack.
Place here has honey vanilla lattes in the fall.
Yum.
Yummy, yummy.
You guys are making me hungry.
I finished making stuffed bell peppers.
Oh my god, stop!
That sounds delicious!
Okay.
Resting glitch face, you're invited over to the maid cafe to cook.
Only for me.
Not for the patrons.
They can fend for themselves.
So come over here.
You have two minutes.
Can we use the stove?
No, it's preoccupied.
It's busy.
Late breakfast.
Girl, you had brunch.
Oh my god.
Take me to brunch first.
Reporting for duty.
Guess I'm chopped liver, huh?
What?
No!
Anybody who is willing to cook for me can come over.
Okay.
I just need food.
Can I cook you mushrooms?
Nevermind.
Anybody who is wanting to poison me...
I can make toast.
But can you deliver a mean toast?
Gosh, I hate this.
The awnings and everything.
This place sucks!
Get me out of here, Lord Farquaad, please!
I'll be good.
We're only 42% cleaned.
Skip it?
Can I?
Can I skip it?
I wish they let you choose what level you want to do.
Power Wash Simulator, please.
Please, Power Wash Simulator.
Please let me skip the level.
I'm not feeling relaxed anymore.
Skip it, skip it.
Let's at least get the ground.
Was that cigarettes?
Was that like a cigarette butt?
What was that?
Herb-crusted lamb chops.
Stop, it sounds so good.
I'm so hungry.
You probably have level 2 unlocked now.
Probably once we get to...
What's it called?
Halfway, maybe.
Wait, don't they message you?
Aren't they just like...
Hey, by the way, I have another place that needs cleaning.
Can you like...
They message you.
They're just like, oh yeah.
Can you also handle this other place that I have?
So we just gotta get to there.
Doki had it at 46.
It was intended to use detergent on?
But they don't even give you...
I mean, they'll maybe have jetpacks.
Thank you.
What do you want with the jetpacks?
I feel like I've been asked this before.
What are you trying to do with the jetpacks, huh?
Got my first Vtuber merch the other day from Green Lady.
Green Lady doesn't really narrow it down.
I feel like I might be falling into a merch rabbit hole.
Enjoy collecting.
What is this?
Oh, it's a knight.
Wow, this is actually pretty...
Execution.
Wait.
This is a crime scene.
There we go.
Clean that lash?
Yeah.
I'm not cleaning this at all.
This is real art.
What's that guy who, like...
Does art and then, like, burns it or something?
Or shreds it or something?
This could be Banksy art.
I didn't know his name.
Bubsy is right.
Oh my god, look at him now.
I do want to keep getting the floors though.
What if we, like, clean so much that he disappears and does the whole, like...
Bling bling!
You did it!
New name, Bubsy.
I want to do the karaoke soon.
When we get the message, I'll do the karaoke.
Over here looks good enough.
Right?
You wouldn't... Hold on.
If we even... Up here.
Like, if we went up here...
And here... And here... And here...
You don't look at that side.
See, like, from here... Oh, wait!
We gotta clean those... We gotta clean those ears.
Clean the ears.
Okay.
Clean those... Those guys out.
Oh, they're so filled with wax.
Okay, here we go.
Can you hear better?
Let me know...
The sound of breaking.
Sorry.
Did you hear the break?
Is it not dirty all around?
Just certain parts?
Okay.
Heard a little rat.
My eardrums were pressure washed out of my skull.
And that's how you do it to them.
Never let them know...
What you'll say next.
Because they can't hear.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Let's clean up some of this...
So that...
So that we can...
Make it look nice.
Even if it's a fake nice, you know?
46?
Okay.
Hello...
Farquad...
I'm waiting for your call...
Tonight...
For you to say...
That I can leave this place...
Let me leave this place...
Oh, please...
We're at 46%.
Come on!
You can install an extension to increase your power washer reach.
But it's not letting me buy anything, is it?
Oh my god!
The long long extension!
Have you watched any anime this season?
I wasn't expecting anything besides ReZero, but Science Saru...
Is cooking with Dandodan.
I actually haven't watched anything.
I haven't even started ReZero.
It's a fake fan.
Is it because I don't have those soap nozzles that I can't buy the soaps?
You think?
I'm gonna buy this long extension.
And this...
Wait, now...
Long extension... Well, I don't need it right now.
We need the stubby gun.
I bought it, but I'm already up here.
A little bit of a waste of my money.
But that's fine.
I've seen the Dandodan opening.
The Creepy Nuts song.
It is quite good.
I do feel that they have...
They're one of those types of bands.
Kind of like Yosobi, where they...
I don't want to say their song sounds same-y, but they definitely have a distinct style.
So it's like...
You hear it and you're just like, oh yeah, this is their song.
Very much like Yosobi.
Oh, no, no.
There we go.
Nice.
Nice!
What was the other one that they did somewhat recently?
And I was just like, oh my gosh, this is from the same series.
When I heard the Dandodan opening.
Oh my gosh, I wish I were those birds.
Free.
Able to leave this horrid city.
Yeah, that one.
Please.
Let me spray it.
Let me clean.
Mom!
It's in my blood.
I was born to be a cleaner.
Nice.
The way the guy raps is just so distinct and unique too.
Yeah!
Yeah, it's their style.
Oh, it does work, like I said.
It does work.
You don't think that the text is timed, right?
Rather than being like a...
Like a...
Progression thing.
Dang it, this is the haircut.
Wait a second, this is...
This is a hair salon?
Shrek, you don't have hair?
Denied, denied, denied.
What a liar.
Never trust a bald person with cutting your hair.
He's got little white hairs like an onion.
He does?
On his head?
As a bald person, I approve this message.
Okay, let's get the other ear waxing.
Surely...
Surely then...
We'll get the text to leave this place.
Surely, we will be able to leave...
After cleaning this.
Surely...
We'll be able to free...
Be freed from this prison.
The Lord Farquaad...
Has...
Imprisoned us in.
Who's Shirley?
Your mom.
This is a neighbor.
She's very nice.
I came over.
Last night, I went over there last night.
After I met your mom.
Don't laugh, you guys.
Don't laugh.
That was lame.
Good woman.
That wasn't...
It's like my worst bit.
Wait, I can do the long.
Nice.
Extension.
Oh my gosh, it's really...
Shooting.
Can you rank your own bits?
What are my bits?
Actually, number one bit...
Which is not even a bit at this point.
Truly like...
Another part of me.
Is Frogbert.
Frogbert.
Vtuber Y is a good one.
Can I get...
I don't know if I can take credit for that one.
Can I technically take credit for that?
Who knows.
I can.
It's funny when...
Sometimes...
You know...
There will be like clips of whatever.
Things I say.
Things I do.
And I'll see like comments from people.
Just being like, wow.
This girl has to watch...
This one channel.
She probably got this idea.
Vtuber Y or whatever.
From this channel or something.
And they'll name a channel of...
Something I've never even heard of before.
And I'll be like...
Like I know I'm not so original.
But it's just funny when people are like...
Oh yeah, she had to have gotten the idea from here.
No, I just...
It just came to me.
Kangol-chan copypasta.
Can I take...
Am I allowed to take credit for that too?
I don't know.
Am I allowed to take...
We're reaching into territories.
Did I get this poll?
Oh wait, I didn't finish it though.
Guys, we're at 48 and I didn't get the text!
Would it be okay to take a well behaved 4 year old to a maid cafe like maid dreaming or at home?
Yeah, I think so.
I don't think they have any rules...
Like, I think it'd be fine.
That's not a dumb question.
He's busy.
Like I said, you don't think it's timed, right?
Where Doki took more time or something and...
That's why...
They gave her the option sooner.
Probably took pity on her.
They were like, don't you want to play the rest of the game?
You can check the menu for other missions.
Let's see.
Wait, under...
If I leave... Wait, if I click this...
Oh, Shrek.
No...
Okay.
Guys...
Sorry.
Guys, sorry.
Can you remind me of the name of that famous actor from La La Land?
Mr. Ryan.
Oh, blacksmith.
I thought these would be more like funny haha things, you know?
His name is Ryan.
Ryan who?
Oh gosh, I can't remember under pressure!
Okay, is Ryan...
There's only... It could only be one or two.
One or two.
You guys pick one or two.
Pick one or two.
Reynolds?
Two.
Gosling.
In my head, two was Gosling.
One was Reynolds.
Two is correct.
Reynolds.
Ryan Reynolds is from La La Land.
You're welcome.
Gosling, sorry.
Ryan Gosling...
Is from La La Land.
No, that is not the real Ryan.
Maybe I have to watch this part.
See, we're at 50%.
Lord Farquaad, please.
Where's our phone?
Let me out!
City of stars...
Are they calling just for me?
Calling my name...
What was that name again?
It's like when you're just like...
Oh my gosh, I was...
I've had to do that before where I was just like...
I couldn't remember somebody's name.
They were just like...
Oh yeah, you can just write my name on it.
And I was like...
How do you write that?
And they were like...
They were like...
Michael?
Stupid Sharky!
Thanks for 6 months!
Oh my gosh, your profile picture is so cute.
What happened to the old one?
And I was like...
You know, sometimes Michael could be with a K.
Sometimes...
Like Stephanie.
Is it with an F?
Is it with a PH?
Nobody knows!
When MGSV TPP came out, that was the first MGS I played.
Forgive me.
All is forgiven.
Or not?
It could be... You don't know guys.
It could be...
Can I buy the... Hold on.
Can I buy the...
I like how it just says Shrek here.
Shop.
It's still out of stock!
Oh my gosh, I bought that extension for the cleaners for no reason.
I bought this soap nozzle for nothing.
It cost me 75 bucks!
We got scammed real.
And for some reason it won't let me buy these ones.
You have set soap bottles for DLC levels.
But it won't let me use it either though.
I can't even use it.
Scammed real.
Scammed for real.
The Farquaad head was not even clean this entire time.
Eat up, Lord Farquaad.
A soap nozzle.
Oh my god.
This is life changer.
Oh my gosh.
It's going away so fast.
It's working.
Wait, only 2 liters.
I can buy some more?
Maybe I can't buy more.
Will it let me buy more?
There's a soap limit.
This game hates us, for real.
This game hates us.
Wait, what is this one?
Oh, this is the spinny one.
Yeah, the spinny one is pretty good.
Because it gets in those good nooks and crannies.
She hates us.
Doki bird?
Surely he texts at 60%.
Yeah, maybe you guys saw wrong.
Maybe he texts at 60%.
You know?
Maybe.
You guys saw wrong because it was like...
Maybe it was the opposite.
She had 40% left.
The real question is, does this game hate you more than you hate us?
That could never ever be possible.
Nothing can...
Nothing...
I hate you guys the most.
Nothing can ever compare to the raw, unfiltered hatred I have for every single one of you here in this chat and watching the VOD, listening to my voice right now.
I hate you guys so much!
I hate you guys.
You hear that chat?
We are irreplaceable.
E Trash!
I've been jamming.
Thanks for 6 months of jamming.
Can you do that again as Lilac?
No.
I'm not...
I'm not here to fulfill your sick fantasies.
I hate you too.
I swear to god.
I'm throwing you in that river.
ESL here.
Is hatred a synonym for care and love?
No.
I could never say that I love you guys.
I could never say that.
If I ever said that, I would catch on fire.
Because I just hate you guys so much.
I would rather die again than say how much I love you guys.
I would rather die again, and again, and again, and again, and again, and again, and again, and again.
That's just how much I hate you guys.
Alright, I'll get the knife.
Okay, 55% baby.
Maybe...oh wait.
Look right here.
This part needs to be cleaned.
Let's just get the roads clean.
Look,
it looks so nice.
Come on Farquaad, let me go.
It looks good.
It looks good, please let me go.
Maybe I have to get a little bit of each area to be freed, you know?
Maybe I just have to...
Just get a little bit of a taste for each area, you know?
And then he'll say, okay, good enough.
Do you remember that one wisp who hitchhiked from Mexico to Animate Fest for you?
Yes?
We know about security in Hamtaro Circle, but what was the concert staff's thoughts when the audience started chanting, she hates this for real.
Oh, for like...
For like...
What was the last thing I did?
For the Hornet, for off-season?
I think, I don't know.
Actually...
I don't know what their thoughts were.
But they're VTuber fans, they probably know that all VTubers are like this, right?
Goodbye Shrek.
Shrek.
All VTubers are not like this?
What are you talking about?
I'm unique.
Unique New York.
You need New York.
Hi Aminto, I hope you're good lately.
I am!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you too.
Oh my gosh, it's been a while.
Wait, it's been a while since I've seen you sideways.
Hello.
Her hatred makes her stronger.
Well, what else?
There was like that science thing someone mentioned earlier.
Any other anime if you guys are watching this season?
Anything else?
Maybe I... I know I need to watch ReZero, it's just getting through the hour and a half long episode.
First episode.
Tower of God?
Wasn't that a webtoon?
Or am I crazy?
Oh, nice!
We got it.
It was.
Right?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
The head is not... The hair is not attached to the head?
Why is the head not a complete thing?
Yakuza fiance?
That sounds so up my alley.
Wait, is it like a cute romance show?
Because if so...
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna be weird.
Shoujo AF?
I've been really wanting a good shoujo anime recently.
I suppose you may be wondering why I didn't go to rescue my betrothed personally.
Here it is, here it is.
Yes, Farquaad.
Why?
I would have of course had I not scheduled the quest to commence on the same day as my official crown fitting.
I see.
So maybe I should go.
Why isn't my afterlife a shoujo anime?
Not quite.
I've been busy with work and the gym.
I finally got back down under 200 pounds and dropping.
Oh my god!
I'm incredibly happy about it, hoping I can get to 160 so I can cosplay again.
Wow!
Look at you go!
Congrats.
Holy cow.
Motivation.
Mental gains.
Okay, Lord Farquaad, was that it?
Was that seriously it?
Let me out of here!
Let me out, please!
What a tease.
Oh my god, not in the good way.
Please.
Let me out.
Click the Shrek button?
This one?
But it only leads me to this place.
Six minutes already?
Oh my gosh, Nicholas, thank you!
I need to show up more often.
What are you guys abandoning me for?
Click new?
Wait, what do you mean new?
Oh, wait.
Was I up in there the whole time?
Yes?
No.
Don't look at that part.
It kind of looks like the city has been burned a little bit, huh?
Here, we'll do this angle.
We'll do this angle.
Time for some karaoke on top of a scaffolding.
Don't jump.
What if I did?
Just kidding.
OK
What should I sing?
What should I sing first?
Yeah, I'm a ghost guys.
I can flow.
All Star or...
All Star.
Oh, sorry.
Smash Mouth.
Somebody once told me the world is gonna roll me.
I ain't the sharpest tool in the shed.
She was looking kind of dumb with her finger and her thumb in the shape of an L on her forehead.
Well, the years start coming and they don't stop coming.
Fed to the rules and I hit the ground running.
Didn't make sense not to live for fun.
Your brain gets smart but your head gets dumb.
So much to do, so much to see.
So what's wrong with taking the back streets?
You'll never know if you don't go up.
You'll never shine if you don't glow.
Hey now, you're an all star.
Get your game on, go play.
Hey now, you're a rock star.
Get the show on, get paid.
All that glitters is gold.
All these shooting stars break the mold.
It's a cool place and they say it gets colder.
You're bundled up now, wait till you get older.
But the media men beg to differ.
Judging by the hole in the satellite picture.
Ice we skate is getting pretty thin.
The water's getting warm so you might as well swim.
My world's on fire, how about yours?
That's the way I like it and I never get bored.
Hey now, you're an all star.
Get your game on, go play.
Hey now, you're a rock star.
Get the show on, get paid.
All that glitters is gold.
All these shooting stars break the mold.
Wait, I want to do this in front of another location.
Right in front.
Oh, don't look at that side.
There we go.
Hey now, you're an all star.
Get your game on, go play.
Hey now, you're a rock star.
Get the show on, get paid.
All that glitters is gold.
All these shooting stars.
Somebody once asked me could I spare some change for gas.
I need to get myself away from this place.
I said yep, what a concept.
I could use a little fuel for myself and we could all use a little change.
Well, the year's back coming and they don't stop coming.
Bent to the rules and I hit the ground running.
Didn't make sense not to live for fun.
Your brain gets smart but your head gets dumb.
So much to do, so much to see.
So what's wrong with taking the back streets?
You'll never know if you don't go.
You'll never shine if you don't glow.
Hey now, you're an old star.
Could you give up?
Go play.
Hey now, you're a rock star.
Get the show on, get paid.
All that glitters is gold.
All these shooting stars.
Break the mold.
All that glitters is gold.
All these shooting stars.
Break the mold.
Yeah!
Yeah.
What if I just search Shrek?
Here we go.
Love was only true in fairy tales.
Meant for someone else but not for me.
Love was out to get me.
Not the way it seems.
Disappointment haunted all my dreams.
And then I saw her face.
Now I'm a believer.
Not a trace.
Of doubt in my mind.
I'm in love.
I'm a believer if I try.
Right guys?
I thought love was more or less a given thing.
I'm a free giver but the more I gave the less I got.
Oh yeah.
What's the use in trying?
All you get is pain.
When I wanted sunshine I got rain.
And then I saw her face.
Now I'm a believer.
Not a trace.
Of doubt in my mind.
I'm in love.
I'm a believer.
I couldn't leave her if I tried.
You guys believe in ghosts, yeah?
Da, da, da, da, da, da.
What's the use in trying?
All you get is pain.
When I wanted sunshine I got rain.
And then I saw her face.
Now I'm a believer in ghosts.
Not a trace.
Of doubt in my mind.
I believe in the paranormal.
I'm in love.
I'm a believer.
I couldn't leave her if I tried.
Then I saw her face.
Now I'm a believer.
Not a trace.
Of doubt in my mind.
Now I'm a believer, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now I'm a believer.
And then I saw her face.
I'm a believer.
Not a trace.
Of doubt in my mind.
Now I'm a believer.
OK,
I got another song.
I'll zoom out a little bit.
Sorry.
C minor.
Put in C minor.
Oh.
Where are all the good men gone?
And where are all the gods?
Where's the streetwise Hercules To fight the rising odds?
Isn't there a white knight Upon a fiery steed?
Late at night, I toss and I turn And I dream of what I need.
Kick it, boys!
I need a hero.
I'm holding out for a hero Till the end of the night.
He's gotta be fast.
Strong, he's gotta be fast.
And he's gotta be fresh from the fight.
I need a hero.
I'm holding out for a hero Till the morning light.
He's gotta be sure.
And he's gotta be soon.
And he's gotta be larger than life.
Larger than life.
Somewhere after midnight In my wildest fantasy Somewhere just beyond my reach There's someone reaching back for me Racing on the thunder And rising with the heat It's gonna take a superman To sweep me off my feet
Up where the mountains meet the heavens above.
Out where the lightning splits the sea.
I swear that there is someone somewhere watching me.
I forgot this part, whoops.
Through the wind and the chill and the rain.
And the storm and the blood.
I can feel his approach like fire in my blood.
I don't remember that part.
Like a fire in my blood, like a fire in my blood.
I wonder if you could mix here.
Ok, nevermind.
This isn't a karaoke stream.
I need a hero.
I'm holding out for a hero till the morning light.
And he's gotta be sure and it's gotta be soon.
And he's gotta be larger than life.
I gotta get a new home to escape.
Wipe out.
Oh no, the tempo changed.
Oh he's gotta be strong and he's gotta be fast.
And he's gotta be fresh from the fight.
I need a hero.
Hero.
Wait a second, hold on.
We go back in time.
No, no, no, no.
Do it again.
Here, here, here.
Hold on.
I skipped it.
Ok, hold on.
My blood.
I have something to say.
Shrek is cute.
I like him, I like him, I like him, I like him.
I finally found my prince.
The reason I was born.
To meet Shrek.
Let's live our lives together.
I love you the most in the world.
I love you.
I need a hero.
It works!
I'm holding out for a hero till the morning light.
And he's gotta be sure and he's gotta be safe.
And he's gotta be larger than life.
It works!
Pan Matsuri!
And you can do the Pokemon Pan right there too.
Thank you.
Shrek's Onion Matsuri.
I can't believe you can Gachikoi Kojo in the middle of holding out for a hero.
Oh no, it's playing it again.
No, no, no.
Alright.
Let's go to the next place.
Let's go to the next place and I might... What other songs are in Shrek?
What other songs?
Minto Believer.
Thank you Poki.
Accidentally in Love.
What is that one?
Living La Vida Loca!
Okay, we'll sing those when we get to the next place.
Or let me do a little bit of the next area.
New.
Hanzo's Honeymoon Hideaway.
Oh no, this is disgusting.
Mud baths by fairy light.
Picnics by the sea.
Banishments by angry villagers.
Pure bliss.
We're cleaning up their aftermath of their honeymoon?
But time flies when you're having fun and now that we're due to check out the love goggles have come off and I can see the mess we've made.
Shrek's Not Bothered says anyone renting out their place to a pair of loved up ogres is asking for trouble.
But I disagree.
On the heart?
Oh my god.
Am I wearing... I'm wearing gloves, right?
We don't go inside.
But even the...
What are you doing in my...
In your what?
Oh my god, get rid of it, please.
Get rid of it.
I don't want to know.
I don't want... Get rid of it.
Get rid of it.
Alright, we're not at the swamp, are we?
Why?
Do you want me to be there, Shrek?
I'll leave right now.
Shrek and Fiona freaking out.
Wait, is it really... Did it really appear?
No, not yet.
This is where... This is how Shrek 3 happens.
Guys!
Beware the love onion.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, but this level is so much more doable to get to the swamp.
You know?
Why do they start you off with the largest level ever?
No wonder Fiona had three babies!
Stop.
I wish them a happy lifetime.
This isn't even place number one.
It's place number two.
Also, why is Shrek texting me about this place?
He doesn't own it?
Oh my gosh, it's so beautiful here though.
What is it called?
Mintz...
Hentai Haven.
Hentai... Heaven.
Heaven.
That's what the HH stands for.
The freak shack.
Hansel and Gretel's...
Oh, honey... Oh, Han... Not just... Nope, sorry.
Gretel does not get any...
Any credit.
Just Hansel's honeymoon hideaway.
The HHH.
Can you see?
Oh, you guys want to go to Mintz Hentai Heaven?
Well, first of all, it's very expensive and exclusive.
It's not really for anybody to just wander into, you know?
You gotta be really... You gotta be invited and stuff.
I have cash.
But do you have nerve?
Do you have... Do you have the strength?
Do you have the mental fortitude?
Have you guys ever watched hentai and then... Well, not just hentai.
But also like, you know, jav.
And then put them on like 2x speed.
But then also put them on 0.5x speed and they sound like a seal.
They're like...
Try it next time.
Can we leave here?
No.
Oh my gosh, it looks like broccoli in the distance.
Oh my gosh, there's the other hideaways!
It's just silliness, you know, when you do it.
It's just kind of a fun activity, you know?
I have half a McDouble and a used Q-tip.
Oh, I'm so hungry.
Fine, you're in.
Access granted.
Honestly, you could pay me off with food.
Especially right now.
Why is it dripping?
Oh my god.
I walked into Min talking about hentai and jav.
No, I'm saying, you know, it's silly if you listen to it at 0.5x speed...
And they sound like a seal.
You know?
They're like...
Hey, Oshi puts the Oshi in fujoshi.
You'll never unhear it, I promise.
Actually, don't do it if you don't want to ruin your experience, I guess.
This place is making me hungry.
The gingerbread house is so yummy looking.
We will forsake our countries.
We will leave our motherlands.
We have no nation.
No philosophy.
No ideology.
It is our only home.
Our heaven and our hell.
This is hentai haven.
Mint big freak phantom.
Perfect.
The perfect speech.
Honestly, that speech lives, like, so rent-free in my brain.
I mean, anything Metal Gear lives rent-free in my brain.
Who am I kidding?
I can't tell if these are dirty or if they're...
Oh no, they're just speckled.
What can you eat this place?
Do you think you're allowed to?
Would you want to now?
I'm cleaning it.
This is multi-purpose and it's huge.
I'm just gonna use the...
Soap.
Let me know...
Oh, I don't know why you're bothering.
The place looks fine to me.
Shrek.
Shrek is just like...
Anybody wants to...
Anybody would, you know, see this and get turned on.
Although there might be the odd blob of snot.
It feels kind of cozy.
Alright.
The snot.
It's the snot.
Wait,
there's something written on the roof.
What does it say?
T.T.
T.T.T.T.
What does it mean?
Maybe Cortex is gifted!
It says mint?
No, it doesn't.
But we can make it say mint.
Hold on, I have to write something else.
It provides ghostly energy?
Experience?
Wait, what did you say?
Thank you!
Hold on, I have to write more.
I have to...
I have to clear my name.
Hold on.
Oh gosh.
I'm stuck.
Okay, hold on.
But this freak was not me!
This...
This freakiness was not me!
Freak Mint was here!
Freaky Mint was here, but this freak...
I do not take credit for this.
I don't take credit for this.
Yeah.
Two freak, five me.
Oh wait.
There we go.
Bing, bing, bing, bing.
I love the sound of money, baby.
We...
We love it.
We love to hear it.
Even on the insides.
They just left no surface untouched.
Nowhere is safe.
Incredible.
Oh my gosh.
I wonder if there...
Actually, there are ogres in the milking farm universe.
So...
Maybe they need an ogre farm.
I don't know.
Just a suggestion.
Cha-ching, baby.
Thanks for the coin.
Thanks for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please don't reward me for my words, though.
You guys make me feel bad when I say bad things.
And then you reward me for them.
I feel quite guilty.
Don't do that.
Okay.
I know.
I know sometimes I say things that shouldn't be said.
Okay.
So it's our fault now.
No, no, no!
That's not what I said.
I'm just saying, don't reward me.
I think you should get worse.
Really?
I could.
I could get way worse.
Thanks for the super chat.
Maybe another day.
And I'm feeling a little more freaky.
I mean, this place is freaky.
This place has it all covered, everybody.
I mean, it is covered.
But it has all the freakiness handled, rather.
You know?
I don't need to do anything else.
Time to go all in on the freaky.
Oh my gosh.
What's wrong with you guys?
You guys need to calm down.
You're dirty dogs out here.
You're all dogs.
One day Mint will sing arguably one of my favorite Metal Gear songs.
Invisible by Duran Duran.
One day.
Maybe.
Unless I never do that.
No, I'm just kidding.
Probably one day.
You guys have to hear...
You guys know the... What's their names?
Eiffel...
The guys that made...
Eiffel 65?
65.
Yes.
They have a song.
They have a song...
Called...
I think it's called My Console.
You guys should look up the lyrics.
Actually...
I'm just gonna karaoke it right now.
Wait, I don't know the song.
Nevermind, I can't karaoke it.
You should look up the...
I don't actually know how it goes.
Maybe next karaoke.
Which...
I think I have actually...
It's funny, I have two karaokes.
Well, I have like...
A lot of karaokes planned during my...
Somehow it happened that way.
Planned during my...
The decking?
Shrek!
I suppose there might be a slight stain by the decking.
I was boiling up some slime covered toadstools for a late night hot toady.
And it exploded everywhere.
It's a hot toady.
I forgot to use this yesterday.
Football!
Thank you!
But...
It was only supposed to be one karaoke and I got...
And then I got...
And then some plans happened and then...
And then I had to split the one that I was going to do.
Really kicked itself on the wall, sorry about that.
Yeah, you should be.
But then one karaoke turned into two.
If it all works out, hopefully.
But yeah, so...
It's for my debut...
It's on my debut week.
That there will be more karaokes.
Yeah, yeah.
The reason...
Oh my goodness.
I won't say yet why it all got split up.
But...
Yeah.
Should be fun.
Hopefully it all works out.
And is a good time.
As long as your voice holds up.
Oh yeah, it's been like two weeks.
I'll be fine by then.
My voice has gotten much better.
But sometimes I still squeak but my voice has...
Recovered a ton.
You don't even know.
So I'm all good.
I think.
I look like a sniper when I have the long one.
While I lay down.
Yeah.
I just also really just wanted to do karaoke with my new model.
With my new look.
Big lug...
Lug...
Love from Burger Squad.
Thank you, Chris.
In just a box.
Thank you.
Yeah, big lug.
I don't even know where that...
Usually I can tell where I mess up on words because my brain is like...
Combining two together, you know?
But I don't know.
I think I saw the Q in squad and my brain interpreted it as a G.
And so I just smushed it all together into big lug.
Usually there's like...
There's a method to my madness.
Usually makes sense.
Usually.
My brain does work in strange ways.
I don't know.
I have such trouble reading and speaking.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why I'm a streamer.
When all you do...
Well, streamers, all they do are read and speak.
That's the thing I have the trouble with the most.
I believe it's been already six months.
Me neither.
Six whole months.
Six months I'm getting a new look.
You know, it took six months to get a new look rather.
I don't know.
I'm sure there's like guesses about who my new model's mama is.
Of course I'm gonna...
Even if it's...
Even if you know or think you know.
I won't say.
I won't confirm or deny, you know.
But...
I originally wasn't going to ask them.
I was like...
I had actually a few other artists in mind.
Because I thought maybe they would be busy or...
I wasn't sure.
With stuff like that.
But luckily it worked out.
So...
Happy about that.
Why are you the most chaotic power washer I've seen?
What are you talking about?
This is fine.
But...
Yeah.
So...
For anyone who's just like...
Of course.
Of course Mint went with that artist originally.
I was not going to.
Am I happy I did?
A hundred percent.
Thousand percent.
Absolutely so happy.
And you guys will be like...
Fresh Mint looks so...
Fresh and cute.
Maybe.
Hopefully.
So...
But...
Yeah.
It wasn't like...
Oh, I didn't want to go with the artist.
I just was like...
I don't know.
I was like...
You know, if they...
Are busy and stuff.
Mint 3.0 is Mint after taking a shower.
But Mint looks cute even now.
But I can go beyond.
I can go beyond.
It's power washed Mint.
Essentially.
So excited for Fresh Mint.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm like...
Trying to be so patient.
But guys, my patience is...
Is waning.
Even though it's not even...
Nothing is complete.
So I literally can't even be like...
Oh, everything is done.
I just have to wait until the day.
No.
I can't even...
I can't...
Nothing is complete.
Hold.
I must hold.
Just as you must...
When you are waiting for my stream...
To begin.
I must also hold.
For my own stuff.
How do you think we feel?
I think I have way more impatience.
I felt kind of silly...
Announcing it with so much time in advance.
I was like...
What's the word?
It's a whole month.
That's a ridiculous amount of waiting time.
Because I initially was going to...
Have my birthday be the debut day.
I just was like...
You know, I'll just announce it instead.
Gotta build the hype.
But there's so much...
There's such thing as like...
Waiting too much time...
And then people forget about it.
You know?
That's what I feel.
One thing I can say is...
There may possibly...
Here's a little...
Since you guys are watching...
I'll give you guys a little preview...
Or like a little...
Something something.
There may be...
Some...
This is...
And this is kind of why the karaoke got broken up.
There might be some karaoke guests?
Special guests?
Maybe?
Thank you!
I don't know...
I've literally...
I don't know if you could guess any of them.
Nice.
It's fine debuting at the end of the month?
Gave me something to look forward to?
Yeah, if all goes well.
It's on Halloween.
It's like, you know...
Halloween is a...
Important day for me.
I'm a ghost.
Guests?
I asked some people.
So we'll see.
Hopefully, you know...
Everybody I asked said yes.
Hopefully, they're not too busy.
And are able to do it, you know?
To make it.
Will there be candy?
There will be...
Eye candy?
A.K.A.
Me?
There will be...
Yeah, that.
Right?
I'll take your entire stock.
Of what?
Can I leave now?
Not yet.
Shrek is not granted his permission.
Maybe we need to do some of this.
The onion.
Why is it purple?
Sexy!
Then there's all that...
Stoge...
Down the side of the house.
What is that?
We were having a romantic mud bath...
And I caught a few fairies...
In bottles for soft lighting.
Oh my gosh.
If I was a fairy...
That'd be kind of messed up.
But also maybe deserved.
Then to create the full spa experience...
I let off a real barrage of bubbly stinkers.
Can you imagine Shrek typing all of this with his fingers?
Guess the smell was too much for the fairies...
And they died.
I'd prefer you as an elf.
Yeah...
Maybe me too.
I mean, but fairies, elves...
They're close enough, right?
They're close enough.
They're pretty much the same.
Them fairies are small and evil.
I mean, you don't have to be...
You don't have to be small and evil to be a fairy.
Is it supposed to be green?
Okay, yes, it's supposed to be green.
Oh wait, let's see if we can go now.
No!
Almost maybe.
Maybe almost.
Shrek, please.
Don't you need someone to clean your house?
Your swamp?
Maybe I need to get the purple up.
And that will be like...
Because...
I think there's like...
From the pictures I saw, there's like purple at the swamp and stuff, so...
I want to see...
Don't care.
Are we there yet?
In the Hanzo's honeymoon hideaway job, wait in the onion.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
You could get an achievement for just chilling in the onion.
I like you just the way you are, Minton.
Thank you!
Green.
Thanks for accepting me at my worst.
Nice.
We're not going back to this though.
Cease.
Nice.
Interior clean.
Big ol' wheels.
Oh my gosh.
Just like an onion.
You peel the layers.
To reveal your true self.
How did they...
Oh my god!
The just married sign!
Wow!
It's legit.
They actually did it.
This onion...
Oh my goodness, sorry.
This onion looks so rotted.
This is what my brain would probably look like if you took it out of my head.
The onion pre-washed, you know.
Not the onion now.
Now the onion looks nice.
But the onion pre-washed probably would look like my brain, you know.
Just soiled.
Absolutely.
With many thoughts.
Many different types of topics.
Oh my goodness.
Why are so few ghost girls in games?
I don't know.
I think there's a lot of ghost girls in games, I'll be honest.
But, you know, I don't know.
I think people hate ghost girls.
We're not very sought after creatures, I guess.
Trap seals?
What a silly name.
Let's see.
This is good, this is good.
Oh, this one?
A little bit more.
Oh, there we go, that's why.
A lot of skeptics in life.
But you guys literally are seeing me.
You guys are seeing me in the afterlife.
Like you are...
You are witnessing me.
Oh, no.
Are we though?
Yes!
Where do you think I am?
Luggage chest.
Oh, there we go.
More stuff.
There we go.
Nice.
Trying to get in all these little side areas.
Luggage row.
You guys are able to see me.
Kind of, I think.
You guys have like a good sixth sense, you know?
Found a game with the latest episode of Digital Circus has a cute ghost girl.
Yes!
I watched it.
And like a really spooky ghost thing.
That guy is so scary in that...
The freaky ghost.
Oh, nice.
I can get up here.
Nice.
Okay.
Easy now, easy now.
Don't want to slip off.
Freaky ghost man.
Nice.
We must get to the swamp everybody.
We must get to the swamp.
So close.
At the swamp.
We'll see.
Did you get on the roof too?
Yeah, I did a little bit.
I guess I actually... Let's do this for the roof.
Freaky mint was here.
Yeah.
Did I eat yet?
No, I didn't.
It's okay though.
I'm a tough cookie.
Just like this house.
Wait, it says this is made of wood.
Nevermind, sorry.
This is multipurpose.
I'm using the wood.
Oh my goodness, I messed up.
Okay, this...
Okay.
Yeah, multipurpose.
I was going to say, is this not gingerbread?
Oh, I think it's out.
That didn't last literally two seconds.
Stubby.
I think we maybe need to get to 75%.
75%, baby.
Let's go.
75%.
Nevermind.
We need to go...
Try wide nozzle.
Oh, this one, right?
The 40?
Since we're right here.
Up and close.
Come on.
To the swamp.
Oh, but it doesn't really penetrate well.
Come on.
You disgusting...
How did it get...
How did it turn to black?
Yeah.
But this freak...
Was not me.
Mold.
Oh my gosh.
They just like...
They have to actually like tear down this place because they made it so disgusting.
It just actually grew black mold.
And so, anybody who lives here will just die.
It does look like they molded...
Like maybe they got the gingerbread house wet.
Wait, but that's what I'm doing too.
Mysterious.
80%.
Yeah!
The roof might be a wee bit scorched too.
Oh, scorched.
The one thing we didn't think about.
It was a fire.
Revenge lightning.
Not going into it.
Ra...
Raiden?
Let's just say we got on the wrong side of someone down at the beach.
Revengeance?
Lightning?
Raiden?
Oh, dragons.
That would make more sense.
I think so.
Maybe a little bit.
This game.
It's killing me.
I mean, I'm already dead, but...
There's a...
What's it called?
Shrek is based off of like actual...
Wait, we'll do this one.
Like actual...
Folk tale, right?
A book?
Yeah.
Has anyone ever read it before?
It was a kid's book.
Was it...
It's not Brothers Grimm, is it?
Or like...
How old is Shrek?
Thanks for getting me into Metal Gear.
I really liked it.
It almost made me gay.
Oh, it's more recent.
The 1900s.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
I've never heard of it until the movie.
Don't say it like that.
I learned that from Matara.
Looks like there's a bunch of bird poop all over it now.
Or how it is.
88.
Come on, 90.
Come on, once we get to 90...
It will be...
Letting us through?
Letting us in?
The movie is barely related anyway.
No way.
Does it have like all the...
Fairy tale creatures...
In the book, kind of.
That was always like a fun thing, you know?
It was always...
It was always fun when...
Movies and series and stuff would do that.
It would be like...
Look at all these...
Disney princesses together.
Look at all these fairy tale characters together.
You know?
You read some of it to us on your...
Oh, that's right!
Yes, the Shrek!
I remember!
Yes, because he...
What was happening?
Some of the pages, I couldn't tell if they were real or not.
That's right!
I do remember.
Remember who you are.
Oh my god, look!
It's so clean on this side!
Minus a few specks, but it's whatever.
It's like mostly the cleanest it'll ever be, ever.
So close to a hundred.
I know!
We're so close, you guys!
Let's now waterboard anybody living in there.
By sending all the water inside and flooding the home.
It's currently sealed so they won't be able to get out.
Nice!
The fireplace is now ruined.
Yes!
But you know who appreciates that?
Old Saint Nick.
Because he's gotta go down that.
And now it's more mushy for his tushy to fit in.
Oh my gosh, there's so much air.
Good point.
See?
Always think of Santa.
Whenever you do something...
Before you make that tweet...
Before you...
Before you, you know...
Do anything in your life or afterlife if you're alive or dead like me...
Always think...
Would Santa approve of this?
Would this get me on the naughty list?
No, not would Santa do.
How would Santa think?
What would Santa think?
You don't want Santa's disapproval.
Right?
That would be like the most pathetic thing ever.
If Santa even is just like, come on.
You know?
What if Santa is a freak too?
He can't be.
Santa is Santa.
He can't be a freak.
Santa can be a hater though.
Oh, maybe if you're...
Sounds like someone who's been on the naughty list before.
Sounds like something someone would say who's been on the naughty list would say.
Oh, Santa, that guy sucks.
Yeah, why does he suck?
Oh, he's just a hater.
Oh, sounds like someone was naughty.
I think...
Me thinks someone had coal delivered to them.
Me thinks, me thinks.
This icing part is annoying.
You're like an onion for sure.
What made you come to the for sure conclusion of that sentence?
Some angry guy in a wheelchair told me Santa wasn't real.
He made my boss cry.
No!
I bet your boss had a big heart.
Big heart, boss.
Big boss for sure.
The H is silent.
Big boss.
Get it?
There's a H.
The big boss.
Big boss.
I'm stuck.
Screw that wheelchair guy.
Yeah, all my friends hate that wheelchair guy.
Wouldn't ever want him showing up in my chat.
Oh my gosh, grass are here.
Should I ban you just for the giggles?
Just for a little...
Hee-haw time.
A little funny moment.
Always do it for the bit.
You'd understand, right grass?
You'd understand.
For the bit.
Yeah, still banned in Doki's channel.
Not that my Doki was like, how do you know about grass?
Because grass came to my channel.
Sad about being banned at yours.
So sad.
What even did you lie about?
What lies were told?
I think it's pretty messed up though.
I did not lie.
I hate Santa.
No!
He wasn't even wrong.
Doki just didn't follow the directions correctly.
It's always like that, isn't it?
Like, you can't blame the streamer in those kinds of situations.
Streamer brain is in real condition, okay?
I'm sorry.
Streamer brain gets the best of all of us.
98%, you're right!
Now it's all just the tiny bits here.
Oh wait, I did get that donut.
I kept thinking I didn't.
We're so close, guys.
We're so close.
I can feel it.
Do you think we can get to the...
Nope, okay.
Okay,
you definitely...
Oh my goodness.
Let's bring this around.
Okay, okay, okay.
Here?
Nice.
Let's switch to the extender.
I cleaned something.
Nice.
99%!
Okay, what's... Wait, what is it?
There's a way to see what... Oh, here.
Alright, let's start at the bottom.
Side window frames.
I see it.
1%.
1?
Did I get it?
Oh.
1 out of 2.
Side walls.
This whole wall.
Oh, I see, I see.
Hold on, I'm getting the icing while I'm here.
Nice!
Underneath here probably is a thing.
Yup.
Under here I think I got.
It looks pretty clean.
Okay, what else?
You guys...
Roof icing.
Let's do that last.
This kind of looks hellish.
It's actually pretty hellish, so...
This one...
Oh, okay, it's just a tiny bit of stuff everywhere.
Oh!
2 in 1, baby!
3!
Okay, nice.
Rear eaves.
Oh, here?
Definitely disgusting.
Nasty.
Nice.
One more?
Okay.
This one looks clean.
I'm like tilting my head up trying to say these, you know?
Ding, ding, ding, dopamine hint.
I know!
Oh gosh, we still have quite a bit though.
The chimney!
Oh, there is one more chimney donut!
Which one?
I knew I was missing one.
The top one!
Clear.
Column candy canes!
3 out of 4.
Column candy canes.
I tried.
Tried to get it while I fell.
Oh, front eave, we got that one.
Maybe I can get it from here.
Nice!
Roof icing.
What was I trying to clean?
Oh, these candy canes, that's right.
Get every little nook.
Every little bit.
Nice.
Was that the last one?
Column gun drops.
Mario, this one.
Got him.
Okay.
Deck bases.
This one.
Where are you not clean at?
Oh, down here?
The deck meringues.
Which one is not clean?
You?
Where at?
Oh, all over.
Got him.
Oh my gosh!
One more?
This one?
Where at?
Oh, from behind.
Got him.
Front door handle is like only 89%.
You?
Okay.
Front skirtings?
Oh, okay.
Let's do this.
Let's do...yeah that.
Notice that stuff too.
There we go.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I can taste it.
And it's not just the gingerbread.
Front wall?
Extend.
Where at though?
Where is it not clean?
Taste the front wall?
I did.
Taste delicious?
Fantastic.
Look at all this clean, clean, clean...
Front window frames?
Nice.
I'm gonna go up.
You guys, it's fine.
I used soap earlier, remember?
It should be fine.
I used soap.
Right?
It's okay.
I used soap to...oh, dang it.
Let's move this.
I used soap to clean it.
It should be all clean now.
To lick...
You could eat anything off of it.
Now.
Probably.
Soap can't wash the sins.
Heart sign somewhere.
Which one?
As someone who does this job IRL from time to time...
I can tell you, less than $200 for all that is insanely cheap.
Like, that only cover labor a short...
Cover labor a short driveway.
Without using any soap.
You're telling me you don't use soap?
Wait, which heart is it?
Am I crazy?
Did you guys see it?
Heart sign centers.
Oh, wait.
Heart sign.
Oh.
Here.
Oh, the heart sign.
I thought I was talking about the heart window.
What a thrill.
Heart sign poles.
Okay.
Candy cane.
I love hearing my armor kind of go clink clink when I jump.
It was just... Was it both of them?
Both of them.
Okay, this one is not clean.
Where though?
Where else?
Oh, here.
I could barely even see...
Nobody would even notice that!
Onion carriage axle.
Oh, we didn't finish the onion carriage.
Axle.
This one.
Got it?
Oh my gosh, guys.
We're like...
We've been at 99% forever.
Onion carriage window sill.
Here.
Stand up.
Oh, I see it.
Okay.
That's it!
Onion carriage driver's seat!
Get me out of here, please!
The driver's seat?
Got it?
Flatbed railings?
What the hell is that?
Oh, here?
Got it?
Roof icing!
This one is going to be hard to see because...
I know we got this one, I'm pretty sure.
But they're all white, so we don't...
We're not going to see them glowing very easily.
I think.
Okay, here?
I'm pressing tab.
Pressing tab.
So much.
Okay.
No, we're not going back to that horrible Duloc.
We're never going back there.
We're going to get this.
We're going to get this!
Come on!
Where else?
There's lots of stuff, actually.
Down here.
Right here, in the corners.
Where nobody ever looks.
Oh my gosh, I'm launching myself.
I'm crazy.
Yes!
Two more?
This corner.
Is it underneath?
We're free.
That's why I see it.
I see it.
I have the power of the sight vision.
Complete the Hanzo's honeymoon hideaway job!
Let's watch us do it.
But not like Shrek and Fiona's do it.
That's us, baby!
I have to give it to you.
It does look maybe a wee bit different now.
And not in a bad way.
We might even get our deposit back.
Still, no time for chat.
We've got to pack up our things and get out of here before those villagers find out where we've been staying.
As great as it's been, I can't wait to see my swamp again.
I just hope we don't come home to any surprises.
What is Washalot?
What is this Pokemon?
Don't just stand there looking all cool and metallic.
Come on in!
Don't you worry about that beware ogre sign.
You're perfectly safe.
Well, normally you'd be toast.
But Shrek and Fiona are away on honeymoon, which is just as well.
You see, me and the gang got a bit carried away at the wedding afterparty when Shrek and Fiona had taken off.
It would be great if we could, you know, make all that mess go away.
Washalot is a pun on wash and lancelot.
Oh, it's me!
Let's put it this way.
If Shrek comes back and finds a swamp looking like it's looking right now, I'm going to need a lot more of that flying pixie dust.
Thanks, Donkey.
I'm guessing it's Donkey.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, we're here!
Oh my...
Wow!
Oh, Donkey!
Donkey really... I think it looks better this way.
Why do we need to change it?
Can I go... I can go inside!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, wait!
Wait, Shrek... What the... What is that?
A fairy.
Hob's end feet?
What happened in here?
On the table?
Isn't this where it was?
Wait, where's the kitchen?
Oh, right here.
Where Donkey said...
I'm making waffles!
Just like the movie!
We can reenact all of our favorite stuff!
Oh my gosh.
Your helmet airtight?
You might want to keep that on.
The air around here gets pretty...
Beefy?
I smell like beef.
Yeah, those gloves too.
Where are you watching me from, Donkey?
Come out.
Can we go in here?
And the armor.
We can recreate this too.
Okay, ready?
I'm a ghost, it's fine.
Let's clean this one and then we can sing here.
Oh wait, why am I doing the inside?
There we go.
Gotta make it just like the movies!
Just like the movies!
It's a cool place and the city is cool.
Did they really say that?
Do they really think that it's gonna get cooler?
So they say.
The void.
Everybody can see in here.
There's not even toilet paper!
Oh my gosh.
Everybody can... Can I get in here?
Oh my gosh, I'm going into the hole.
Ideally, there's nobody in the swamp.
I guess, but look!
Okay, this is a POV.
You're squatting on the toilet.
Anybody can come up through here?
Just be like, howdy.
Anybody home?
Look, there's a hole there.
Howdy doody.
Public restrooms in the US also have massive gaps around the door.
You're so right.
Oh my gosh, you're so right.
It's horrible, it's awful.
If you've never been to a public restroom in the United States, it is an actual culture shock.
It is actually so horrible.
And like, always at the airport...
They're always so wide at the airport specifically.
And like, I can see people.
Like, I have to make an active effort not to...
Not to look for real.
You know?
Like, it's just so bad.
Oh my gosh.
Like I said, it's actual culture shock.
I kind of want to clean this off just a little bit for our karaoke.
Even if we just do a light dows.
So it looks a little bit more like the movie.
This is basically like when a film is shot at a location.
Like a regular house.
And then someone moves into the regular house and they paint the house color.
But, you know.
The AI summary made you low?
Why?
What is it saying?
All that glitters is gold.
Riaju Buckhut.
Wow, there is a lot around here.
Wow.
Can I clean through here?
Wow, cool.
What's this?
This probably says...
Minto number one.
It's a mirror.
Nevermind.
Oh my gosh, this is where Shrek bathes.
This probably says...
Minto number one.
Danger.
This says...
Mint X Snake forever.
Beware of...
This one says...
This one says, come on in.
Stay out!
Who would've thunk, man?
So close.
Yeah, so close.
Like I said, we'll do karaoke soon.
I just wanna make it look a little bit more...
Cleaned up, you know?
Look, we're already so close.
This looks like a purple tentacle.
It looks like a purple tentacle, like, reaching from the ground.
Take your time.
Thank you.
Oh, we ran out.
I just realized.
Dang it.
It goes so fast.
It goes so quickly.
Let's get out of here.
One time I was in a public restroom.
Someone I had unsupervised...
Oh, someone had unsupervised small children peeping through the gap.
I had to go yell at their parents.
Oh, that's awful!
I haven't had it personally happen, but I've seen people have kids crawl under the gap and everything.
Why did the mobster keep a live animal next to his locked door?
It was the donkey!
That's a good one.
That was a good one.
Just a little bit more.
All this glitter comes off really easily, luckily.
So, we can just clean it up.
Make it look almost brand spanking new.
And sing some songs.
All that glitters is tree trunk.
It wasn't gold after all.
No.
It's the Great Deku Tree.
This should be good.
You probably can't see the rest, maybe.
Oh, here we go.
Let's get some of this.
Just wash it all off.
Wash it all off.
Yeah.
Alright, let's see from over here.
See?
This is doable.
I do kind of want to get a little bit more of the...
Of the glitter on the ground.
Anyway, Shrek asked me to mine the swamp for him while they're on their honeymoon.
Yeah, and...
What happened, Donkey?
Donkey, what happened?
Donkey, what is all of this?
He had like a... Just a fairypalooza.
He didn't ask exactly, but best friends don't have to.
Okay.
Unsolicited.
This isn't his dragon.
You see, when Shrek saluted as they drove away in the onion carriage, I saw that unmistakable sparkle in his eye.
It said, Donkey, this is your home too now.
Watch over it.
I trust you and believe in you.
That's a lot to say in just a sparkle.
This isn't all...
Donkey's dragon friend, is it?
Like the Frodo Gandalf sparkle.
That'll do, Donkey.
That'll do.
Wife, you mean?
Oh, sorry, yes.
How could I forget it?
Oh, they did get married!
Back in the 2000s, as I traveled the world, I used to collect pictures of graffiti inside bathroom stalls, port-a-potties, etc.
But sadly, that collection was lost.
I don't get the joke.
Wait, I don't get it.
I don't think it was a joke.
No!
Your collection was lost!
Oh my gosh!
Here, we'll celebrate.
I mean, not celebrate, we'll mourn.
L for lost.
Was it that?
This game is really like, once you get going, you just can't stop.
Don't stop coming and they don't stop coming and they don't stop cleaning and they don't stop cleaning...
Guys, I made it relevant to the story!
Lost!
Why am I even cleaning up the dirt on the ground?
It doesn't really make much sense.
Like all of this.
It's a swamp.
It looks natural.
It looks like it's supposed to be here.
You know?
It doesn't... I didn't even know I was supposed to be cleaning this part.
But it's dirty.
Yeah, it's a swamp.
I got rid of the evidence.
The dragon.
That was a big old dragon foot.
I saw it.
Big old dragon print.
Oh my goodness.
There we go.
Okay, this should be good enough.
Yeah, good enough.
Alright guys.
Let's do some karaoke.
I know I did some of these songs earlier, but I'm gonna do them again.
I'm gonna do them again.
Actually, let's move... Let's move it over like that.
Yeah, okay.
And then I'll be here.
You can tell it's Shrek, right?
Wait.
I discovered the Chocomintosong cover you have during the time you were gone years ago.
But do you think you'd sing it in karaoke sometime?
Oh maybe, but it's like a two person song.
Okay.
Shrek.
This is official karaoke, so I have to have reverb on.
It's coming.
Wait, this is actual... It said donkey.
Sing it, Puss!
It's a duet with Puss in Boots!
She's got a new addiction For every day and night She'll make you take your clothes off And go dancing in the rain She'll make you live her crazy life But she'll take away your pain Like a bullet to your brain Upside, inside out Living la vida loca She'll push and pull you down Living la vida loca Her lips are devil red And her skin's the color of mocha She will wear you out Living la vida loca Living la vida loca Living la vida loca
Hey donkey, that's Spanish!
Where?
What?
I woke up in New York City In a funky cheap motel She took my heart and she took my money She must have slipped me a sleeping pill Wait, this is your part.
Shrek!
Upside, inside out Living la vida loca She'll push and pull you down Living la vida loca Her lips are devil red And her skin's the color of mocha She will wear you out Living la vida loca Living la vida loca Living la vida loca Come on!
Oh,
she's living la voca Why aren't you saying your part, Puss in Boots?
Break it down!
Upside, inside out Living la vida loca She'll push and pull you down Living la vida loca Living la vida loca She'll push and pull you down Living la vida loca Her lips are devil red And her skin's the color of mocha She will wear you out Living la vida loca
Shrek, what did you say?
I can't believe there's a Shrek version of this song Donkey
This song implies the existence of New York City in Shrekverse It does!
I can't believe there is a...
I cannot believe there is a Shrek version of that song Like official What is this one?
I don't know it, but I'm going to play it Let's see Donkey
This is like the theme song Party, party, party
How does this go?
In the way you look at me There's a smile, there's a truth in your eyes What an unexpected way On this unexpected day Could it mean this is where I belong?
Is that you loved all along?
What?
There's no mystery It is finally clear to me What?
Is that lyrics?
My heart searched for so long What?
And it is you I have loved all along There were times I ran to hide Never showed the other side What?
I'm too much blown away No, it says Shrek Film Now I know just who you are And I know you hold my heart Finally, this is where I belong Hi and welcome to my membership It is you I have loved all along There's no mystery It is finally clear to me You're the hole my heart searched for So long It is you I have loved all along You
guys, there's a song from the musical that's called Freak Flag
Portable hops and a name
Over and over I'm filled with emotion Your love, it rushes through my veins And I am filled with sweetest devotion As I, I look into your perfect face There's no more mystery This is finally clear to me You're the hole my heart searched for So long And it is you I have loved It is you I have loved I don't know what I...
Harry Gregson Williams worked on the Shrek OST and backing music?
Yes Shrek and Metal Gear Solid are tangentially related They are connected Can you believe?
I'm a believer
I thought love was only true in fairy tales Meant for someone else but not for me Love was out to get me Now that's the way it seems Disappointment haunted all my dreams And then I saw her face Now I'm a believer Not a trace of doubt in my mind I'm in love I'm a believer I couldn't leave her if I tried God,
love was more or less a given thing The more I gave, the less I got Oh, yeah!
What's the use in trying?
All you get is pain When I wanted sunshine, I got rain And then I saw her face!
Now I'm a... not a trace No, no, no, no, I'm doubting my mind I'm
a believer I couldn't leave her if I tried And then I
saw her freak What's the use in trying?
All you get is pain When I wanted sunshine, I got rain And then I saw her face!
Now I'm a believer Not a trace I'm doubting my mind
I'm a believer I couldn't leave her if I tried And
then I saw her freak Now I'm a believer Not a trace I'm doubting my mind Now I'm a believer Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Then I saw her freak!
I'm a believer!
Not a trace!
Na, na, na, na, na!
I doubt in my mind!
Yeah.
What other songs are from Shrek?
Wait, what's the one?
You guys said about something...
Um...
Uh...
Oh, Accidentally in Love, thank you.
I don't know that one.
But, we'll try it.
This one, maybe?
Tell me if I'm right or wrong.
I might recognize it.
Is it from the original one?
Is it?
Second movie.
Wait, I think I might know this one.
So, what's the problem, baby?
What's the problem?
I don't know, but maybe I'm in love.
Think about it every time.
Think about it, can't stop thinking about it.
How much longer will it take to cure this?
Just to cure it, cause I can't ignore it.
If it's love, love.
That makes me...
I don't know nothing about love.
Come on, come on.
Turn a little faster.
The world will follow after.
Come on, come on.
But as everybody's after love.
I'm a snowball running.
Running down into the spring.
That's coming, all this love.
Melting under blue skies.
Belting out sunlight.
Shimmering love.
Well, baby, I surrender.
To strawberry ice cream.
Mint ice cream.
And all this love.
But I didn't mean to do it.
But there's no escaping your love.
These lines of lightning.
We were never alone.
Never alone.
No, no.
Come on, come on.
Move a little closer.
I wanna hear your whisper.
Come on, come on.
Settle down inside my love.
Jump a little higher.
Come on, come on.
If you feel a little lighter.
We were once upon a time in love.
We're accidentally in love.
I don't remember it so well, but I'm trying.
Accidentally in love.
Wow, this song is so cute.
This song is so cute.
Let's do another Shrek 2 song.
I sang both of these next two.
Actually, I think I sang all of these ones.
Where have all the good men gone and where are all the gods?
Where's the streetwise Hercules to fight the rising odds?
Isn't there a white knight upon a fiery steed?
Late at night, I toss and I turn and I dream of what I need.
Hit it, boys!
I need a hero.
I'm holding out for a hero till the end of the night.
He's gotta be strong and he's gotta be fast and he's gotta be fresh from the fight.
I need a hero.
I'm holding out for a hero till the morning light.
He's gotta be sure and it's gotta be soon and he's gotta be larger than life.
Larger than life.
Somewhere after midnight, in my wildest fantasy.
Somewhere just beyond my reach, there's someone reaching back for me.
Racing on the thunder and rising with the heat.
It's gonna take a superman to sweep me off my feet.
Mountains meet up above and where the lightning splits the sea.
I could swear that there's someone somewhere watching me.
It's you guys!
Through the wind and the chill and the rain and the storm and the flood.
I can feel his approach like the fire in my blood.
You're watching the stream!
Hero!
I need a hero.
I'm holding out for a hero till the morning light.
He's gotta be sure and it's gotta be soon and he's gotta be larger than life.
Now!
Hero!
Nevermind!
Oh he's gotta be strong and he's gotta be fast and he's gotta be fresh from the fight.
I need a hero!
I forgot to do it.
She forgot.
I even just did it earlier.
I'm trying to see what other songs.
What is bad reputation?
I don't know it.
I'm gonna listen to it and see.
Maybe we know.
What is my backup call there?
I don't give a damn about my reputation.
You're living in the past of a new generation.
A girl can do what she wants to do.
That's what I'm gonna do.
I don't give a damn about my reputation.
Oh no.
Not me.
I don't give a damn about my reputation.
Never said I wanted to prove my sensation.
I'm only doing good when I'm having fun and I don't have to please no one.
I don't give a damn about my reputation.
I can't say this.
No.
Not me.
Oh no.
I don't give a damn about my reputation.
I've never been afraid of any deviation.
I don't really care if you think I'm strange.
I ain't got a chance.
I don't really care about my reputation.
No, not me.
Oh no.
Not me.
Hello boys.
I don't give a damn about my reputation.
I can sing this the right way.
The world's in trouble and there's no communication.
I'm not singing this right at all.
And everybody can say what they want to say.
It never gets better anyway.
So why should I care about my damn reputation?
Anyway, not even close.
No.
Not me.
Oh no.
I don't give a damn about my bad reputation.
Living in the past is a new generation.
And I only feel it when I got no pain.
That's how I'm gonna stay.
And I don't give a damn about my bad reputation.
Oh no.
Not me.
It's punk so...
So it's okay if I sing it wrong?
Yippee!
It's punk to sing it incorrectly too you guys.
Break stuff is also in check.
I don't think so.
I don't give a damn about my bad reputation.
What did I not sing?
Oh, this one.
Okay, two left.
Or rather, I have sung this one but earlier.
And I kind of messed it up so...
But you don't really care for music, do ya?
It goes like this.
The fourth, the fifth.
The minor fall, the major lift.
The baffled king composing Hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
It's too loud.
Your faith was strong but you needed proof.
You saw her bathing on the roof.
Her beauty in the moonlight overthrew ya.
She tied you to a kitchen chair.
She broke your throne as she cut your hair.
And from your lips she drew the Hallelujah.
I think I was just singing off the top of my head.
Hallelujah.
Maybe I've been here before.
I know this room, I've walked this floor.
I used to live alone before I knew ya.
I've seen your flag on the marble arch.
Love is not a victory march.
It's cold and it's a broken Hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
There was a time you'd let me know.
What's really going on below.
But now you never show it to me, do ya?
Moved in you, the holy dove was moving too.
And every breath we drew was Hallelujah.
Maybe there's a God above.
And all I ever learned from love.
Was how to shoot at someone who outdrew ya.
And it's not a cry you can hear at night.
It's not somebody who's seen the light.
It's cold and it's a broken Hallelujah.
Thanks guys for watching me play Powerwatch Simulator Shrek Edition.
The final song, of course, is the song.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
And let's go.
Let's go!
Beautiful Hallelujah.
Thank you!
Somebody once told me the world is gonna roll me.
I ain't the sharpest tool in the shed.
She was looking kind of dumb with her finger and her thumb.
In the shape of an L on her forehead.
Well, the years start coming and they don't stop coming.
Fed to the rules and I hit the ground running.
Didn't make sense not to live for fun.
Your brain gets smart but your head gets dumb.
So much to say, so much to do.
So anyway, I did the wrong part.
Never know if you don't go.
You'll never shine if you don't glow.
Hey now, you're an all star.
Get your game on, go play.
Hey now, you're a rock star.
Get the show on, get paid.
All that glitters is gold.
Only shooting stars break the mold.
Hey, it's a cool place and they say it gets colder.
You're bundled up, now wait till you get older.
But the meteor men beg to differ.
Judging by the hole in the satellite picture.
The ice we skate is getting pretty thin.
The water's getting warm so you might as well swim.
My world's on fire, how about yours?
That's the way I like it and I never get bored.
Hey now, you're an all star.
Get your game on, go play.
Hey now, you're a rock star.
Get the show on, get laid.
All that glitters is gold.
Only shooting stars break the mold.
Hey
now, you're an all star.
Get your game on, go play.
Hey now, you're a rock star.
Get the show on, get laid.
All that glitters is gold.
Only shooting stars.
Somebody once asked, Could I spare some change for gas?
I need to get myself away from this place.
I said, yep, what a concept.
I could use a little fuel for myself.
And we could all use a little change.
Well, the years start coming and they don't stop coming.
Fed to the rules and I hit the ground running.
Didn't make sense not to live for fun.
Your brain gets smart but your head gets dumb.
So much to do, so much to see.
So what's wrong with taking the back street?
You'll never know if you don't go.
You'll never shine if you don't glow.
Hey now, you're an all star.
Get your game on, go play.
Hey now, you're a rock star.
Get the show on, get paid.
All that glitters is gold.
Only shooting stars break the mold.
And all that glitters is gold.
Thank you!
Thanks guys!
Otsumito!
Thank you for the stream!
Thanks for the Shrek karaoke!
Bye bye!
They don't stop coming, they don't stop coming!
World chaos, reverse world chaos fits perfectly in the instrumental break.
OK.
Bye!